what is this dude dude the fact that
they chose to for this is like it makes
sense but it's also oddly infuriating
yeah you can't choose a guy who did both
yeah and it doesn't feel epic at all it
just feels like the Montage that feels
epic is like the best yeah this just
feels like we're talking about what the
Rivalry is yeah you need like what's his
name Liv Shriver the the guy who does
hard KN yeah the Hard Knock guy yeah
yeah t needs that money huh yeah I hate
when you take like a catchphrase that
meant something when someone was in the
heat of battle and turn it into
something that a middle-aged dude saying
on a
couch are we up and running Kevin uh
yeah we're good are people on the are
people in this
[__] oh can we put can we put the stream
with Joey Avery just so people know guys
if you're watching this is Joey Avery
very funny comedian he's been on
flagrant before friend of the friend of
the show friend of mine and he's from
San Francisco but he's not a cuck
believe it or not okay A little bit of a
cuck he's a little bit of a c and uh
obviously I had to call him for this
live stream we're going to try to do
this every cowboy game guys uh shouts to
priz Pi by the way they're sponsoring
this thing I made picks on the game so
prize pick is you just pick it's like
fantasy but you pick more or less so I
picked Dak Prescott you're going to like
this less than 242 and a half yards I
love that that's a great pick that's a
lock lock and the two kickers combined
more than three and a half field goals I
just feel like the defenses are good so
that's my picks I love that I think
that's great we'll get you on prize
picks we'll get you to pick too but uh
whatever you just tell me whatever you
think so you're from San Francisco you
know football which is rare for a
comedian that's another thing that
excites me yeah most comedians don't
watch at all I'm always shocked by that
I just assumed everyone watches football
and then I like post stuff about
football and it doesn't engage I'm like
I thought this is what we were all doing
every Sunday all day I thought that's
how you the way you became friends with
a man was you know Sports I know Sports
we talk about it that's right and then
we throw in what girls we think are hot
slowly and then it just builds yeah
exactly this is the only way any
friendship to happen yeah it's the way
bar stool built its entire
how I think you just were supposed to
make friends and I'm shocked at the
we're in the minority it turns out not
just with comics in the world most
people don't watch
sports yeah but what are it's not like
there's something that's bigger than it
it's just that people have other things
that's true no that's true there's just
a lot of things going on yeah but then
it feels good when you actually go to a
game and you're sitting in a stadium and
you're like okay yeah this is b d I went
to the I went to the Clemson game uh on
Saturday who' they play they played Wake
Forest oh they destroyed him or no
Clemson's not very good but I was in
South Carolina doing shows and uh my
buddy coaches the Wake Forest
quarterback so I was sitting with the
Wake Forest band and it was tight you
get to go sideline no I I was not I'm
not that important I got to get my
numbers up I I got close seats to a
football game one time which means I
snuck down from the top to the bottom
one time before they kicked me out and
the thing that blew me away was how big
they are like you know they're big but
when you see them everyone is a monster
full pads like linemen are monsters dude
it's it's scary dude and especially
games on on Sundays I've been down on
the sideline once and you like if you're
like a little hung over and you see two
guys Collide like that I'm like oh God
I'm like too sensitive for it sometimes
all right the game is started it's it's
00 you guys I assume lost the toss and
the Cowboys deferred I hope yeah I
missed the toss it doesn't really matter
and mcaffrey or Chris mcaffrey
Christian m Christian mcaffrey his
numbers right now are unbelievable he I
mean chances he gets MVP are very slim
but there's a real possibility if the
Niners keep rolling this way you get a
non-quarterback MVP which would be
unbelievable I just don't think he's
going to hold up all year with his usage
now that was a 15 yard penalty so you
guys gain 20 yards on your first play
yeah but I'm fine with the don't do that
I'm fine with that don't touch my guy
like that I'm fine with that honly this
is the so as a ners fan I can tell you
every Niners group chat that I'm in
we're very happy with how the team's
going we would all like to put Christian
mcaffry and bubble wrap and just have
him not play until the Super Bowl but
that's the thing I don't think you win
without him no I don't think Brock Brock
part's actually good what are your
thoughts on Brock py hav been dying to
talk to you about this yeah yeah I look
I was very skeptical but look at that
absolute dime from the kid okay okay
there's I mean the conversation always
ends up with people being like well he
wouldn't be this good if it wasn't for
Shan yeah he wouldn't have the
opportunities that he's had if it wasn't
for Shanahan's offense and the fact that
every time the uh Niners had another
quarterback their leg explodes yes uh or
they suck but he is doing a really good
job and I'm not a quarterback expert but
a lot of people at first it was like oh
he's limited but they can work with him
but now I'm seeing more and more of the
like film breakdowns where it's like
he's making some Next Level throws Aaron
Rogers was saying that uh he looks good
to him and I okay I'm no I'm more of I I
love football but I'm not going to
pretend I know X's and O's but to me
every pass goes seven yards and then he
has Sam Samuel and Brandon auk who run
30 yards after and then he does this
stupid [__] celebration that drives
me crazy where he gets all hyped up and
throws his arm seven yard pass and then
yeah but that's that's that's I hat it
so much Brock the [__] pry dude that's
what he does look I can't sit here and
pretend that I don't I do that when I
make a good shot in beer pong so like
yeah yeah maybe it's no you don't do
that you don't do that yeah I do no you
don't
[__] a [__] you they let the
special needs kid make a three-pointer
that's what it's like that's what he
looks like to me celebrating like that
got a special needs face special needs
celebration he's a special boy dude is
there another flag on that Mr
Irrelevant
uh oh [__] he's dude he's he's he's he's
you know what future Hall of Famer Brock
pie is he's the truth I'm just excited
for the uh Tre Lance Revenge game oh
yeah yeah are we going to see do you
think you'll see Trey for a snap this
season he should he should run that's
what I thought wild cat him but he's
good enough to you can fake it you can
still throw yeah he's got all the tools
I actually thought he would end up being
good I don't know if that broken ankle
[__] him I mean it it certainly did
cuz he just hasn't gotten a chance to
play and it's oh that's not good there's
a flag though I'm assuming illegal
contact oh okay [__] okay
good I look like cool Steve
Jobs hey I'll take that Luke y you are
from San Francisco uh yeah offside I
knew it was a cowboy penalty yeah they
call me Steve hand jobs hey dude thanks
for the New Zealand $5 I don't know how
much that is but appreciate that that's
a sweet thing to do fantastic dude
that's that's a nice thing to do dude I
told you we'd step it up I was doing it
for two weeks before on an iPhone and it
was a real nightmare and this isn't
great but it's going to keep getting
better we're going to keep stepping it
up yeah this is this is great you got a
lovely office yo this is it my wife has
relegated me to I can't watch on the big
TV you know that is true what is she
watching on the main Housewives of New
Jersey probably who knows probably a
repeat you know what I mean you're
you're working right now that's a side
Room Gig still this is the office so I'm
working so this is great though cuz I
get to watch watch sports and it's not a
problem yeah like it's work I have to
you have to cont there's no other choice
child surprise P for making this a
contractual obligation yeah that's big
I've just uh my wife understands it's
part of life now like there just will be
Sports on all the time the great thing
is she likes it she's like I just feel
like it's comforting noise in the
background and I'm like I'm so glad you
think that CU you will have it for the
rest of your life my wife is from Philly
so she's used to drunk animals screaming
yeah and fighting yeah you watch it too
cuz you don't even drink so you don't
get C no do you get I hate sports bars
really I hate like the rubbing in each
other's face like this is if you win
[__] you and if I but we're not going to
sit here and make it a thing and get
into fights I'm not doing all that right
see I love sports bars and I love
getting hammered but I just always feel
like it's not going to be a fight and
then you get there and you're like these
[__] yeah not for me dude so this
drive is actually very disconcerting cuz
you've marched all the way into the Red
Zone and I don't think you've even had
long third down this is what we do we
just make it look easy you really are
making this look very easy Brock with
that
footwork why not I mean he's wide open
[__] goodness George and he's on my
fantasy team look at him look at him
there what a nice time oh my god dude
this is going to be a nice time I think
oh my God huh fun Sunday oh my god dude
seven plays 75 yards look at GE 10 yards
a play oh my [__]
goodness there's no way this guy's good
he's not good Brock py he's just not
there's no way I don't believe it threw
a touchdown in the NFL there bud
scrambled a little bit you know just cuz
he makes it look easy doesn't blown it
was a blown assignment I promise you
this guy's wide open oh he he spotted it
and he saw it that's something that the
quarterback we just traded to you does
not know how to do yeah [__] me he
doesn't know how to see
that the Cowboys are just making this
game too big that's it that's all it is
yeah this is honestly it's pre season
for us I think until kind of like NFC
Championship game is when when we're
really going to start getting nervous
yeah that's super bowl or bus for us
this year I can't I can't believe Brock
P wins a Super Bowl I just can't I can I
said this about Jimmy Garoppolo too yeah
I saw it with him too but I don't know I
saw a video on Instagram this week of
Brock py he was like giving out a Jersey
to these little kids they were smiling
and stuff and I was like dude I think
he's got it I saw that I saw that exact
same video with Jaylen Herz he lost on
the Super Bowl so just I'm letting you
know also I've seen that video with
Carson Wentz and God knows where he they
all do it but there's a different way to
do it Brock un he had Poise amongst the
children and I when I saw that I was
like he's got the thing dude I didn't
believe that like three weeks ago we
thought Dak had the thing you remember
Cowboy the whole NFL thought Dak had the
thing for the first year and a half yeah
Dak has it he's so poised always it's
always what they'd say yeah they felt
like good dude they felt like they were
really proud to like give a black guy
compl that wasn't athletic so they were
like he's poised that was like the term
left on to yeah yeah he's so poised in
the pocket just poised I don't even know
what that means but uh yeah Brock I I
foresee that for Brock no Brock's
Brock's a superstar he's just you know
this is not true I think I'm believing
anything is possible I initially thought
he was limited but you know what guys
who make it look easy oh god dude I hate
it so much chat is talking about aash
Astro Boy here needs George KD this is
strong getting a lot a lot of getting a
lot of Special Love No you're cool Steve
Jobs true true but honestly special
needs George K Walmart AJ Hawk that's
good too dude these are all compliments
believe it or not I mean I'll take it
I'll be in the same are adonises you're
getting compared that's right the Adonis
of Steve Jobs who thought he could like
eat pears and defeat cancer yes exactly
well you're cool Steve Jobs right you
would take the medicine that's right but
you're [__] right George KD but
again that's not that bad that's that's
not bad at all yeah yeah just a little
bit more r i get told aiz not cool aiz
not never who knows how to get a lady
the white the right wine glass
yeah oh my God somebody just noticed I
have a small head it took you that long
[__] idiot are we on IG live Kev yo
IG if you want to watch the a better
version of this go to the YouTube page
I'm just letting y'all know that's
hopefully I don't know I didn't set that
up so it's kev's fault if it's not good
but uh
hello yo stream everybody says to me say
something racist or say something funny
why don't y'all say something funny as
an Eagles fan that should have been
holding on the offensive line not going
to lie I don't even know what P what
play he's talking about oh the last the
last play oh he's just saying he's an
independent yeah yeah yeah I thought he
saw him about the Super Bowl hold still
how do you feel do you think you're
better than the Eagles this year not
right now here's the one thing I think
this is maybe optimistic but the guy we
drafted Mazy Smith I don't expect to be
good now I think he will be really good
I think by the end of the year he could
be effective against the Run yeah and I
think if we that that's why I kind of
expected I didn't expect this but I
thought y'all would run all over us and
I thought if we played you again it
wouldn't be as bad and we would we have
a better chance later in the year yeah
baring injuries yes well I think that's
what we're both just consider conc ered
about cuz that's what [__] I mean it's
there's no way to avoid it that's
football these dudes are crashing into
each other but it just sucks cuz that
kind of feels like there's always like
four or five teams who could win and
then it's just whoever is healthy at the
right time but here's what bothers me as
a Cowboy fan who to say something that
Eagles fan they don't get hurt ever
Jaylen Herz runs like a running back
right plays he missed what two games
last year right the offensive line is
disgustingly healthy receivers are all
healthy no big dline injuries t was it
was it laye Johnson the right tackle
that's like really good never misses a
game Jason Kel still playing he's 50
years old yeah there's always healthy
well and last year we were healthy right
there until Brock's arm exploded and
then we had to play the NFC Championship
without a quarterback yeah that's true
that's true do you think you would have
won that game though of course I do yeah
I mean you I you I can't say that to any
Philly fan and have them let that go
yeah yeah I don't I was on the I was you
know Chris o' Conor I was uh
Gill's friends I was with him in LA and
Gillis called him and they're
celebrating cuz they're you know Philly
fans and I was like that's [__] dude
we would have won if our quarterback
didn't get hurt he's just like dude we
hurt your quarterback who did that we
hurt your quarterback I was like well
that's actually a fair point yeah I um I
really love Dak and I'm believing less
and less and then as you talked I saw
him overthrow the tight end and I got so
you could see the air come out of me and
I stopped listening to what you were
saying which is fun yeah but that's why
I think Trey Lance is going to be great
for the Cowboys cuz he's also a really
athletic dude who will overthrow the
[__] out of people so you could kind of
just slot right in you know what I'm
kind of hoping they can trade Tre Lance
for like Kyle pittz or something and
just flip it try and get yeah what Happ
probably could use a quarterback I don't
know these just I think Atlanta know how
to use them this is
crazy I mean this is a this is a bad
look so far it's a bad 5 minutes it's
going to be interesting to see total
yards are 75 to one it's it's
but I I do hope it continues at that
pace it's just going to be I don't think
you guys have faced pressure like this
and it's hard for them to do what they
like to do with Dak when people are in
his face this is the other thing this is
the first game that the Cowboys
offensive line in like a year and a half
has had all the starters which seems
good but then they haven't played a
single game together in a year and a
half right this is not a great first
time to find Team chemistry yeah so that
that is disconcerting as well none of
this looks good I'm going to be honest
but I still think they have a chance I
don't know why but yeah on the Cowboys
should get their [__] doors blown
today yeah which is a good game to start
the stream with
really yeah that'll set the toone I
think and honestly if you weren't here
it would just be me melting down for
three hours so I think it's really
better yeah do you do these by yourself
you just freak out and get upset about
the Cowboys I'm going to have to not I
just realized cuz otherwise you want to
balance it out a little bit commiserate
with someone what are your thoughts on
stepen a Smith he always has something
to say about the Cowboys oh I think he's
doing a character him so skip I know for
a fact didn't skip when skip was a
reporter in Dallas he hated the cowboys
that was like his whole character and
then he moved and realized well if
Stephen A is going to hate the Cowboys I
should love the cowboy and that's it
none of it is real I just look at it
like Community Theater well it's also
it's just like it's smart if you're
doing Sports Talk you go after the
biggest market and you make them say
something whether they're happy or sad
they're commenting your clip goes and
he's also so funny at it
he's so good at it he's he's when y'all
had him on flagrant I cuz i' I've seen
him in the sports realm and I've only
seen him talk about sports but to hear
him talk about everything I was just
like he's one of the best talkers on
planet Earth he's incredible when he
talk you just ask him about like being a
single man he's just
like I'm like oh I love this guy dude he
was crazy he saw me with the full
remember I had like the cowboy hat on
the cowboy jersey and then like the
[__] boots and the thing he he he
said look at this guy and then he shook
my hand and then never brought it up
again which is he just refused which is
so funny and so stubborn to be like I'm
not going to give you this and I'm just
never going to acknowledge it yeah it's
a great it's a I'm sitting there with my
legs crossed with a [__] strap just
coming off of me it reminds me of did
you ever see the uh the South Park dock
six days to air it's like about the
making a South Park but they talk about
when they took acid so they went to the
Academy Awards and they took a bunch of
acid and they wore dresses and they're
whole goal the whole time was in every
interview don't address that you're
wearing a dress oh that's great and that
was all they did the entire Oscars
that's awesome such a great move those
guys are the best those guys are the
[__] best I don't think I could do
that on assd I'd be like I'm living Al
lie I need to tell the truth wait I did
shrooms for the first time it was great
when I micro do like a month ago before
the special two weeks before the special
oh really cuz Izzy said he did it before
his UFC fight not the last one that he
lost the one before that right and he
said it helped him so I was like if Izzy
could do it I yeah totally was very cool
I'm going to what was your what was your
experience with it I didn't do enough to
have like the crazy breakthrough I did
like a gram but I broke it up over like
4 hours or 3 hours or whatever right and
you feel like you got and I just had
little thoughts that I hung on to yeah I
was like all right just remember that
that's great yeah I have a different I
have done the full breakthrough where
you like meet God which is awesome uh
and then I just will just do them when
I'm going out sometimes just partying
it's so fun it's amazing yeah you're
just like way more engaged you think
people what they're saying is actually
interesting even when you wouldn't
usually you're just like o why do you
think that oh see I instead of just
moving on going I did it alone and I
love that but Mark was I was here I was
they're in the fridge right now oh
really I took like these little capsules
and then I just went to the living room
my wife was at her mom's place and then
I didn't which was a little bit of a
thing she was like wait you're not you
didn't go to see my mom so he could do
shrooms and I was like yeah I needed to
do it creatively which work that's it's
work true it's work sometimes you have
to do drugs it's your job I just did it
put on headphones it was great Mark
gagnan said he heard it from someone
else this is what weed should
be yeah kind of it just depends I mean
weed is weed you know weed is fun but
you expect weed to be like what shrooms
is yeah because the culture around it is
like kind of mixed together like when
you first learn about weed it's mixed in
with the like psychedelic age it's like
tied eyes and 60s and all that and it's
like that's not exactly what weed is is
right now it's just like a take the edge
off although if you eat like a lot of
weed you can have a pretty psychedelic
experience oh no I just get sick and I
mean it's not even a lot like if I have
like I had uh 5 milligrams of a drink
once which isn't that much but then I
took this crazy hit off of somebody's
pen yeah cuz I don't know how to smoke
which sounds stupid but I either do way
too little or way too much and I like
the room was spinning I couldn't when I
was trying to sleep I I saw like [__]
Tetris blocks forming pyramids yeah see
that's tight which was cool but then I
felt sick for the next day the next I
had to go on stage for 24 hours I felt
sick oh God it gives me like anxiety it
doesn't make me physically ill third and
two Brock's got this no I'm yeah this is
this will be nice and easy little footw
third short is y uhoh there you go God
damn it [__] final that's where the
height comes in a little bit uh speaking
of weed did you see I saw Percy Harvin
said he did not play a snap of NFL
football not high which is electric
dude that's just a lot for me because
I'll be like I I like to smoke but I
won't do it till I'm like done for the
day like I've completed all my stuff
I've worked out I've done my stuff I'm
home I can chill I'll like to do it or
if I'm out drinking or whatever I'll
throw anything in the mix but uh dudes
San Francisco dog wait are you're
married right yeah you got the ring yeah
oh nice sick sick I met you when you
were but a but a boy you know what I
mean I was but boy unmarried but same
gal yeah uh cuz we we met before before
I ever did standup oh wow yeah we were
together like 11 years before uh and she
was cool with the you doing stand up and
being broken yeah well the two things
one Yes actually Believes In Me which is
great two I've had a day job the whole
time so I didn't have to be fully broke
I was like NSF doing Tech sales and then
doing recruiting and then you did chubby
shorts or whatever right yeah yeah good
for you we actually signed the George KD
away from Nike really to Chubbies yeah
dude is it because he felt bad that you
were special needs him basically yeah I
actually I just went up and I started
arranging blocks out front of his house
and he was like this kid needs some help
you know um Kev is the chat saying
anything
useful by the way guys this is again my
first time doing this so it might be
awful I might be trying too hard I'll
get better I'll get more natural he
won't he's never coming back never
coming back dude I wouldn't do this
again
ever but thank thank you guys for
rocking with us man we're having fun
weed culture is annoying that's that's
my so I didn't ever get high till I was
38 my big issue was pot heads were so
[__] annoying shout out to Jay
Victory that's a good [__] yeah I
think I got high uh first time I think I
was like
13 maybe 12 dude you're lowkey a wild
boy low key yeah wouldn't have thought
yeah you're a substance to guy I did did
you I'm a substance to guy you're a
substance guy you like you're faithful
your girl you're monogamous you got a
day job but you throw in US you're a
substance I get a I like to do I you're
a substance Sammy dude I get active dude
on all aspects I'll work the day job
I'll have the Night Dream but I'll party
on the weekend and we'll still find time
for the gym we do the whole thing yeah I
get active dude how much you sleep I try
to sleep a lot how do you do this I try
to sleep about 8
hours um no getting [__] up well the
thing is if you actually I think I sleep
eight hours but I really only do that if
you're not part if you're partying then
you'll you just wear it some days you
know some days you'll have to take five
or six but how old are you uh 32 so it's
you're starting to pay a bit more of a
price but um you if you stay active you
know I just don't want to miss out on
anything like I don't like the idea of
like oh I'm just going to chill like if
I chill at my house I'm probably like
okay I'm going to try and get some work
done or like do something you know I
don't like there's not like a lowkey
moment per se and that like the thing
that I like to do is just hang out and
talk [__] with my friends like me
partying isn't like I'm at like whatever
the cool Club is in New York I'm
probably just like at a table like
yelling at my friend telling me he's an
idiot yeah that's why I like doing that
at the house yeah I don't hate going out
that there's no need yo okay I think Dak
is going to be better if not this drive
than the next Drive he's going to settle
down he's nervous you guys knocked him
out of the playoffs two years in a row
that okay well [__] me well don't don't
don't call that is that Greenlaw yeah
he'll get a little he'll get a little
Buck sometimes yeah he's good he's sick
our defense is sick I got to be honest
your your uniforms are [__] fantastic
they're so good I mean this game is so
aesthetically pleasing yeah really this
is just what you want to see yeah yeah
oh [__] dude it's hilarious like you
watch this and then like you flip to
what was earlier like Bengals wearing
their black pants versus the Cardinals
and it's like what is this the WNBA
get Classy Dog look at that hey two
completions in a row seven yards good
little third down manageable third and
manageable third and short
yeah Bose is a dog oh Javon harra is
someone did a someone did a AI painting
of Bosa shaking hands with Martin Luther
King
Jr yeah these AI artworks are so healing
the country guys if you can drop
pictures in the chat I don't think you
can but send us your best AI artwork all
right third and three this you got to
convert you hat mother [__] yeah
swarming there's
Bosa the Civil Rights leader
himself Dam it breaking the color
barrier of that offensive
line oh [__] me
man getting
outside that was so fast did you watch
uh any of the Steelers Ravens game I
watched a little bit of it what was a
problem today it was like the Steelers
are so their offense is so bad but their
defense is so good they're winning cuz
the defense is scoring points you think
they should trade for Tre Lance by any
chance Trey Lance is not the guy for
them they need like a Kirk
Cousins some the Vikings should give up
on Kirk Cousins right well I don't know
because he if they think they're a
contend like he's not going to make your
team way better but if you think you
have a team that's built for something
he is better than you know he's a
probably a top half quarterback but at
the bottom end of that no I don't even
know if he's top he's top of the bottom
half he's like 16th best yeah it's he's
right there I think the thing that I'm
not like I don't think Dak is Elite but
the thing that bothers me the most is
when they call him black Kirk Cousins it
really [__] bothers me it really
bothers didn't someone in your locker
room call him that that was a a fake
story I think I think an AI story yeah
it was like a Ballack sport story or
whatever like oh yeah yeah it Fly that
that rumor flies around and that stuck
that stuck but a lot of people have run
the like the numbers are the same he's
actually good but he doesn't get it done
in crunch the thing with that he doesn't
get it done in crunch time thing is I
guess maybe some people have a mental
block but also you filter it down one
guy does it per year yeah and everyone
else is like a failure I guess um so
it's a little unfair but yeah being a
sports fan is unfair talking about
sports is just CR criticizing people who
are so good at what they do I know but
it's so fun it's more fun and they do it
to us he's not funny he's not funny Ain
that crazy he's not funny it's a
statement of fact this person is not
funny I've thought about that cuz it
bothers you like I think most standups
like you get into it cuz you're like you
just want people to like like you that's
why you're doing that and then people
start criticizing you and you're like
what the hell this is crazy but it does
come with the territory it's the same
thing as Sports if you want a bunch of
if you want money it means you want a
bunch of eyeballs if you want a bunch of
eyeballs people are going to have
opinions and you want to be talked about
you can't be thinking it's not okay to
criticize you at all you just have to
look at some of them and be like n
you're just wrong and you're an idiot
here's what's here's what my only and
I'm not defending I people should be
allowed to have whatever right but the
he's not funny bothers me because it's
like I say Brock part is not good and we
mean relative to NFL quarterbacks or
what good is in the NFL yeah it if I
said Brock py could not throw a fo
objectively right if I was like he's
just not good at the sport of football
period right it's just a fact right like
there's a half the world is good at
football and he's not one of those
people that's you see what I'm saying
like what are you saying dude but it's a
little bit it's a little closer to
saying he's not a good quarterback which
is wrong but it is something that people
will say all the time yes uh yeah it is
it's just you know you're not for
everyone you know it's like if you're
watching porn and you're like that guy's
not even slinging dick hey that's a
professional that's true all right that
guy's on substances he's got a hell of a
hog but your his stroke doesn't
profession for a reason yeah exactly
that that is why so the best thing to do
is just not read the comments really but
that is why this is the the craziest
thing cuz everyone com have to look at
you know what I
mean well James hopes you're having a
good night so that's ni they keep
talking about our heads really good you
getting you're getting in my head do I
have a big head I don't think I have
that large either I have a small head or
you have a big head or
relatively or both are true or one of us
is making the other person look off
right that's what they're they're
debating in the could be an angle thing
but you
know we'll fix the framing at halftime
uh jron Cur there we go dude I can't
remember any names right now cuz I'm o
ooh you me a little safety Blitz three
yard loss we'll take
it obviously he gets sacked there but
even that's nice he realizes it's broken
he doesn't just get
blindsided yeah he just minimizes damage
so well which which is what you need oh
[__] [__] up he's so good Deo
Samuel yeah he's sick it's really tough
owning Niners in fantasy because they
have so many weapons you can't really
count on a certain amount of points from
anyone like I'll have Debo he'll eat one
week get 25 the next he gets
0.03 but as a fan I'm like that's good
actually we don't want to put too many
miles on him yo what do you think of
Mike
McDaniel uh I when he first went to the
Dolphins and everyone was like this
guy's funny they were playing all the
clips and stuff my initial reaction was
like he's a dork he's not I was like the
whole opposite I was like he is not
funny everything he says is corny they
just like him cuz he's like a white nerd
Who quotes hip hop and they also don't
realize a lot of things I learned after
having this cuz I've reversed the whole
t i now I'm like this guy's hilarious
he's original I love him he's a genius
the
[Laughter]
the Niners have picked up a ton of uh
draft picks because of that rule where
if you if someone in your organization
uh like an assistant gets hired as a
head coach keep black ass head coaches
or the black asso Ryan Mike McDaniel
which again I didn't know uh and uh cuz
he looked like every white kid who
wanted to be black I me he's at a GM's
or an NFL owner's dream right yeah you
just sell
exactly you I mean easy that whole
Donald Sterling don't take pictures of
thing doesn't really apply it's like who
cares dude what do you think Donald
Sterling's up to he's dead right oh I
thought he died for sure dude can y'all
tell us yo did Donald Sterling
die you see dude my hands are I have
normal sized
hands I might be getting angled up but I
feel like I like this guy over here
who is my goat I mean yeah dude Jerry
Rice it it's really hard especially Joey
looks like
sque yo Clinton galb holy [__] that's
good that is the comment of the night
that is good I don't even know how it
makes sense but it's so good I don't
even watch SpongeBob oh that's
good oh sorry sorry to hear that not
Wario that's that's s yeah douge is
Sterling just chilling he's alive good
dude I'm glad thought he
died you can't kill a real
[Laughter]
one big
dude holy [__] dude Squidward's house I
don't even know how it made sense but
it's so funny it's good dude I do you
watch SpongeBob I don't uh I mean I I
watched it a lot when I was a kid I
haven't Revisited it but Squidward's
house I got
immediately uh large nose oh oh flag
what's the [__] Flag we good
Christian what's the [__] FL good
Christian do you remember his dad Ed
mcaffrey you're you're younger you're 30
I'm 39 yeah he played for the Broncos
Broncos wide receiver really [__]
good I think he might have been a Niner
to actually you think I believe I
believe he was [__] knew it would be
off sides [__]
cocksuck and Christian's like a bay guy
cuz he played at Stanford yeah you know
so he and now that the Niners stadium is
in the South p is he still with Olivia
CPO
I believe so I believe God bless dude
God Bless yeah what a winner he's uh
he's one of the few like ba you know
athletes tend to be more religious than
the average Bay Area person Christian
be wow he actually
does oh my God we're going to need to
get a side by side of me and Squidward's
house so [__] that's the AI prompt
that we need to sort
out yo the last time you guys lost a
regular season game I don't even
remember what it
was uh the Cowboys biggest Rivals
historically are the Niners and the
Eagles ah this is awful like the eagles
are like 23 and one in their last 24
regular season games you guys I don't
even know the last time you we we do not
you do not strike fear into us at this
time I
can't Squidward's house that is damn it
the internet is so funny that's your boy
dude that's so
funny oh my God I love how someone put a
hat on it um someone asked if I played
football growing up I played uh I played
football I played Pop Warner for like a
week yeah I remember cuz I played
baseball and hockey were my actual
sports that I was good at but you're
athletic it seems yes yeah I I got into
college for baseball but then I got cut
um what college UC s Diego oh [__] a big
school yeah yeah not like San Diego
State they were the best best D2 at the
time and they just went D1 uh for
baseball but they like had this weird
year where they brought in 15 recruited
Walk-Ons of which I was one and we were
all like I'm on the team and then they
kept one of us so I was going to
transfer and go to a junior college but
then I just didn't and stayed at the
good school and moved on with my life I
love San Diego and I want to live there
San Diego is the greatest and I will
probably what you know the hope with
standup is Achieve geographical
Independence and not have to live in LA
or New York and then I will either go
back to the bay or live in San Diego
those are the only two places I'd go the
bay I hate with all my heart sorry sorry
about the game you know what penalty is
the most frustrating in the [__]
planet is lined up in the neutral zone
it's not even you just you just put your
hand in the wrong place yeah yeah and
that's what when receiver doesn't get
set yeah oh God [__] unbelievable
just point at the ref they'll tell you
yeah um yeah I played football for about
a week to answer the question I got I
remember distinctly I got hit one we're
doing like a tackling drill some dude
put his face mask on the bones of my
hand and that's like a normal thing that
happens in football but it like struck
me and I was like oh I can't do this
dude I literally can't I can play ball
you can hit me with the baseball hockey
I can hit people the pads are soft metal
on the bones of my hand I was GH I'm not
doing that it's simply not for me it's
too painful I got chucked by a big
Indian dude I flew like 15 yards in
football yeah it was crazy dude where'd
you grow up he was a girthy boy uh
near the Niner Stadium South South Bay
like Santa big Punjabi you wear a turban
I maybe Under The Helmet I don't know
yeah he
was giry fell we have a lot of a lot of
Indians down there a lot of oh
oh you got come probably yeah I'd love
to see the replay I think that was a bad
pry pass I think Gilmore needed to pick
that if you don't get the turnovers when
you have a chance with San Fran from
what I understand listening to to
someone else I'm stealing someone else's
point you're [__] yeah yeah that's
pretty the offense moves the ball a lot
so you need those big plays it wasn't
that interceptable no it wasn't no it
was just a little behind the pass wasn't
quite there
but all right second and 15 hopefully
you can just make a little stand here
force a long field goal that's all I
will say Clinton Santa Barbara kicks ass
too i' I'd throw Santa Barbara oh Santa
Barbara if you got money buddy get out
of here get out of here that's is Rich
As [__]
oo or uh parents from there you know you
get a lot of people if you're already in
those areas you're chilling you know
like I'm glad my parents didn't leave
Silicon Valley cuz we wouldn't be able
to go like you'd actually like the area
of the bay that I'm in you think about
like Oakland San Francisco and all that
and I could defend San Francisco but how
I hate it more than any place outside of
Portland yeah I really like it but what
I will say is the the like little towns
like in uh in Silicon Valley are very
nice and you'd like them dirty DNC and
I'm going to be in Portland Oregon I'm
doing shows there check my website for
the exact dates I don't know I'm right
now but
sorry I just had to try to sell no yeah
yeah you need to do that uh Joey ay.com
on tour God damn it dude during my plug
it's trash sorry I'm on tour I'll be in
Toronto this weekend where at uh I'm
going to be in in Hamilton at Levity
Live Friday Saturday and then Sunday
I'll be at the comedy bar uh Dan I've
never been to Toronto OH Toronto's a
great City I'm very excited to go it's
not people keep trying to say it's like
New York I don't see that at all but
it's a great City also if you get hot
let me know I did not turn on the air
because I thought the sound might matter
but no you can pop also there's like a
Loops oh that's important Froot Loops
over Fruity Pebbles I'm going to agree
with that Fruity Pebbles are better at
first but they get soggy yeah instantly
Froot Loops are are a nice
treat oh yeah if you
me you ever are you a you ever rip
cereal dry like that I can't my wife
loves cereal my wife is like in great
shape it's very funny that she married
me cuz I'm if I take my shirt off I look
like a [__] in partially inflated air
mattress but she loves cereal every
night every morning cereal yeah I feel
like if I did that I would like my life
would fall apart dude I don't understand
it and she'll like mix kicks and Fruity
Pebbles and like got Lo she's got a
system about all of it see I always
would like I liked it dry cuz milk is
it's obviously better but I couldn't
believe that I deserved an entire Bowl
so I would just like snag a handful
furtively and just whisk it away to my
quarters and nibble on it like a dirty
little guy great use of the word
furtively yes thank you I will say I
think if you like Fruity Pebbles better
you're probably not good at managing
your money no I like fruit Loop's better
no I'm saying just for these people if
you like Fruity Pebbles better you're
probably you get a paycheck you spend it
you don't know what's going going on you
get your student loan you can't pay for
anything at the end of the year I I feel
like you're that kind of person yeah
someone asked oh that's
out he's out of out of bounds out of
bounds out of bounds out of bound look
out of bounds but I'm going to point
this way let's go you just got a point
till the ref agrees that's how you do it
dog present that beautiful Beacon of
Hope look at these dogs dude on let
dangerous group of see Fred's got it out
are you [__] kidding me dog it might
have touched Fred while he it touched
everyone it touched everyone well well
we don't have that
angle so that's keeps it in oh my
god oh it didn't touch I don't think it
touched
anyone that would be
big someone asked while we're figuring
out who recovered this if you can eat
Froot Loops dry and it's it's actually
just like a butthole you just kind of
have
to you just kind of have to you got to
get that thing
loose open up the old leather Cheerio
there I don't think anyone touched it
dude God Fred looks like a
warrior [__] come on
dude [__] kidding me hey guys can you
just drop some money in the chat cuz I'm
suffering right now only New Zealand
Dollars ideally yeah only New Zealand
dollars that's all my money I wanted New
Zealand Dollars [__] British pounds
dude yellow five and red 40 in MO
cereal yeah what was the one that was
supposed to that the rumor came out that
was Major dick small do you think that
was an anti-asian
propaganda just chose yellow
five yellow five like like a you know
yellow five is like a black
pen yeah know licorice apparently makes
your dick huge
actually licorice root buddy it's
crazy who Josh r that was some BS was it
a fumble or not I don't understand and
my life is falling apart as a Cowboy
fan I mean it was definitely a fumble
the question is that it hit somebody RS
wants to know what I hate about the bay
first of all homeless people taking
shits on the street that's a that's a
problem for me second of all uh the
people the super liberal [__]
annoying cucks everything you hate is
there culturally and then on top of that
they all work at Facebook and it's like
who the [__] are you to pretend you're
liberal when you are working for one of
the biggest corporations on the planet
Earth there's a few things that like
having lived in San Francisco there
really is a Schism between those two
there's like the lip Service Liberal but
we actually vote a lot more conservative
and they'll vote v a lot more
conservative in the like local elections
and then the real like OG San Francisco
like super liberal yeah like the they
hate that but they're getting kind of
squeezed out a little bit Yeah but like
I think that the obviously the politics
of it are a thing um but it just gets
played up so much because it's like the
Bastion of leftwing ism so the right's
always talking about how political San
Francisco is but having lived there it's
like there's a lot of that but it's also
just like if you set that aside and you
just like go out in that town you go to
restaurants you have you can have a
great time there just like anywhere else
and I feel like the homeless thing I go
to all the people who left California
and went to Austin walk around the
streets of Austin I'm like it's the same
goddamn thing Austin they know their
place dude I don't think talk to a real
estate owner [__] like you're
crazy you I mean and they be talking
like they got real estate in San
Francisco the arrogance to these people
it's a fumble it was a fumble [__]
everything
that is immaculate how they unbel oh and
that little hop at the end un [__]
you got to put a little English on it
dude that was a professional play
unfuckingbelievable
teamwork if you eat Min Wheats you have
a high credit score is very funny I i'
love a good Frosted Mini Wheats okay
Fallon is asking the best cities in my
opinion let's let's do this you go first
and then I'll go oh wait hold on you're
about to score a touchdown I want to let
you enjoy your touchdown yes thank you
uh best
cities It's just tough cuz they're so
different like it's hard to compete with
New York on the scale of being a city
that's fair but like San Diego beats New
York's ass in completely different ways
number one that's number one in America
number one yeah I I'm such a homer dude
it's really hard for me I always pick
Bay [__] up and down and I always hang
on to that but it's not an objective
argument yeah so I put San Diego up
there New York I love Chicago Chicago I
was going to name Chicago is [__]
great City I've I've been in the winter
and it's obviously very different
but amazing City yeah super nice people
great food I think you have to R you
have to if you want to do it
appropriately you'd have to do uh weight
classes cuz you can't compare like
Chicago to like Asheville no just what
cities do you like the most that's it
that's the that's what's your favorite
cities you really do notice it when you
go like I hadn't toured a lot until I'm
on like my first tour and I went on a
20day stretch where it was like I went
to Detroit I went to Indiapolis I went
to St Louis you don't really realize
that you've been on the road for 10 days
when you get to like a Chicago and
you're like oh if there's a good
restaurant here and I know that for a
fact then I will sell tickets to this
show and everything every other you up
dude every other City fires you up looks
the exact same yeah it's all just
America's a huge suburb with five cities
yeah so you're I'd never been to
Houston yeah but you're from Texas yes
what are your thoughts on Houston cuz
I've never been and Houston's amazing
okay cuz I didn't quite get it I
couldn't figure out where where I was
and that's why I didn't like it for a
long time cuz there's no zoning laws so
literally a strip club could be next to
a preschool could be and that's crazy
that's Madness but it's just a great
City in the sense that like the people
are friendly it's actually low-key very
diverse the food is great uh the
weather's not bad I mean it's humid as
[__] in the summer but the Winter's
nothing it was very much like La where
was like I never knew where I was but
I'm be like oh there's cool stuff over
here but like why is there traffic we're
in someone's neighborhood yeah that's
that's all crazy it's poor it's poorly
planned for sure but it's a great City
it's a gem of a city yeah Dallas is the
opposite in that it's really well
planned it's I mean people are still
pretty friendly but it's like much
snober yeah it's a beautiful thing but
it's not it's not the same what what
what is the difference between Dallas
and Fort Worth Fort Worth is more like
country okay Dallas is the city that's
like this the Posh super whatever Fort
Worth is at least I mean I moved 15
years ago now but it was like it was
country and it's built up but it's still
like friendlier people the for Worth
Stockyards are there with the bull
riding and [__] like that okay forth is
great too yeah the only thing I saw was
a square with a giant like silver cowboy
hat so that stands out that makes sense
that you're saying country somebody just
gave me $5 said Fruity Pebbles are
better and I managed my money just
fine I mean you can't argue with that
dude that's respect I really
can't aash is Brock party better than
dag no he's not dude and I'm not even
the biggest deck fan but he's not
bad he's not a bad
quarterback Brock party's
unremarkable uh what area of the bay
would I go back to live probably South
Bay I loved living in San Francisco I
really did like the uh what is South Bay
South Bay is like San Jose ultimately
but no one in San Jose actually lives in
San Jose you live in the surrounding
towns I think I like San Jose yes it's
you would would like it yeah there
there's like all sorts of little areas
around there Santa Clara copertino Los
Gatos Mountain View all these like
little smaller towns it's like a nice
place to raise a family except for the
fact that it's completely unaffordable
now and it's it's gone through like
three Tech booms real estate's 4X what
it was you know when my parents moved in
so it's like it's kind of impossible so
all my friends who's let's get in
there all my friends and I who grew up
there and liked it oh did he drop the no
Christian doesn't do that dude he
doesn't Drop the Rock hold on hold on
hold on who's [__] let's keep
pointing dude keep pointing like Joey
said keep pointing no no no we don't
point we can't point for this one he was
down also get off my man dude make sure
he's
okay come up with the [__] ball
please
go
oh yo what's up Brock pie [__] Brock
pie a Christian mcaffrey
fumble Jordan Lewis let's
go let's [__] go I mean go Michigan
but
it's oh so he's so he never touches the
ground same stupid in that cost us the
fumble the F Lally the fact that
Christian mcaffrey is too good of a
running back yes is why that's a fumble
yes cuz he didn't land on the ground
like he was supposed to God but this he
just keeps moving God you guys recovered
the fumble by [__] centimeters you
lost his fumble by centimeters and
really just the Cowboys have worse
slightly worse field position than they
had before so that's all right it's a
wash damn it it's a
wash if you haven't seen Joey's stuff
he's great oh thank you thank you
somebody say I've never seen your stuff
what's your you shouted the channel uh
yeah it it's just youtube.com/ jooy
Avery I'm on Instagram Tik Tok I post
stuff every week very funny promos for
cities
yes yeah I do uh I fake run for mayor in
some of the towns that I'm performing in
great Austin one was very fun loved it
yeah also this is how I knew he liked
Sports because last year I don't think
you still do it but he would make
football picks every week and those were
great so yeah I I loved making them but
they just never did well kind of what we
were talking about at the very beginning
my priz picks I'm oer I haven't won a
single PR no it's not I don't care if I
go oer cuz that is funny in its own
right it just it didn't engage well
because so many people see and my page
is more broad so they're not like
gambling addicts okay
oh I don't mind taking that shot though
yeah you know what I so here I was
actually just thinking about this
earlier today remember when they used
until very recently if you're at your
own one2 yard line you have to run the
ball you have to run the ball yeah why
and I'm glad I feel like we don't need
to do that anymore as sports teams as
football teams I like that that people
have opened it up and realized through
analytics like yeah you got to take your
shots but there's also a limit and that
limit is whatever the Chargers coach is
doing yeah disaster frequently their
offensive coordinator was the Cowboys
offensive coordinator that's right K
Moore yeah and everyone thought that the
Chargers were going to take a huge step
forward this year and that happen you
think so yes get the [__] so you how
do you feel about McCarthy I think
McCarthy is better than I thought he
would be I don't know if he's Elite but
I was very uh like unimpressed with the
higher right and I think at the very
least the Cowboys are more resilient
than they've ever been not that they're
good but before injuries used to destroy
them and now they just kind of keep it
moving yeah and uh I think they're
tougher than they used to be but they're
still not as tough as the ners which
bothers me McCarthy maybe not the Eagles
McCarthy is definitely part of an elite
fraternity which are people who Aaron
Rogers decided were the problem everyone
else decides are the problem even though
he want a Super Bowl with him get
[__] what is that do
dog he's in the dog pound I'm very
disappointed what that is doing just
throw the [__] ball
away it's hard when you got big fret on
you just throw it away right here that's
it you throw it away right there if he
lets go of that Fred might have it you
the thing yeah you just throw it up in
the air 50 y have to launch it yeah I
mean yeah that's what you do you just
launch it all the way out of bounds this
because this is going to be a short kick
that is one thing about running it out
of the back of the end zone or
whatever
woo oh [__] me cop okay Ray Ray who is
this Ray Ray
McLoud he's is fantastic name fantastic
name can't really do it if you're you or
me for a kid yeah I can't probably name
my kid Ray Ray but I'd like to I'm going
to name my kid Ray Ray I would love that
dude Ray Ray sing it's a great name it's
actually a phenomenal name it's great
um someone asked who I would want to be
the Cowboys coach I was actually really
disappointed Mike uh what's his name
mcdel the Miami coach wasn't available
at the time like we didn't know who he
was but I will say the guy I wanted to
be the Cowboys coach was Matt Rule and
he sucked yeah so clearly I didn't know
I was wrong there yeah the great thing
about having hot Sports takes is like
looking back at them three years later
and being like yeah well I guess I don't
oh the triple let him cook oh [__] he's
wi son of a [__] Geor of the Jungle get
in
there special needs George let's
go my guy dude whose house
[Laughter]
Squidwards oh my god dude oh my
God woo and he guesses right after Elias
Brock py trash is
it
yeah the triple
dude that's a Kyle special right there
and a very special
George the only good thing is that my
prize pick of deck having less
than 242 yards looking good but I don't
know if there's going to be any field
goals I think we'll get to some field
goals sha prize picks though the ners
this year I mean this is kind of a
stupid analysis small sample size they
start hot and then a lot of times they
cool off in the middle and they close
strong are you old enough to remember
the Niner Super Bowl like really um I
mean like I was a kid I wasn't like
let's go but I remember like so my
parents every year they throw a Super
Bowl party to this day it's like the one
party we don't rotate families it's
every year we have like 10 different
families come we throw the Super Bowl
party and it started because the ners
were so good like ' 80s 90s it became a
thing they were at the catch yeah um and
so it's just one of those cool football
things where it's like embedded in the
family you know it's like Niners are are
a thing um someone asked if I was
rocking a mullet it's we call it a flawk
you know it's more of a it's kind of a
bit of a mohawk mullet sort of thing but
I need to find a New York Hair Cutter
and tighten it up a little bit we got I
got you I got you I got I got a guy for
you uh by the way someone uh oh the
prize picks Cod is aash by the way I
should mention that and they match your
initial deposit up to $100 so if you put
in 100 you get 100 for free so you
already won you start off up $100 prize
piics code akos AK a a but you should
know that based on my [__] you know
what's crazy is I spell my name
differently than most Indians but
everyone misspells my name to the point
that my email has my name in it yeah
they'll email me and then they'll
misspell my name in the subject and the
body of the email yeah well I was making
the graphic for Instagram today and I
knew how to spell your name but I
checked four times I was like it's
double a right it's dou
a you should call yourself the battery
dude AK doua yeah but it's pronounced
double A Akash it's pronounced a but so
my parents [__] up the spelling and
that's on them did they or is that
just they just decided to do it a little
differently um they tried to take it to
friends in Texas co-workers of my dad's
to see how they could pronounce it and
they kept pronouncing it
incorrectly they focus grouped it with
white Texas
like this iSell thisan not the best way
to do it D very Indian way to do it yeah
it's like a your name is like a
fusion yeah you're like a text I text
text in it doesn't really work but yeah
Tex in Tex in there you go Texon yeah um
someone said I need to put something on
the wall it feels like I'm watching the
casting couch I am going to try to suck
Joey's dick after this and uh he's going
to succeed yeah exactly you're going to
come Squidward's basement
do
wouldn't that be a funny you know these
Mayers do these stupid bets for sports
games yeah they always get they always
get spicy if the ners win you suck my
dick
and that's that's a bet I want to see
it's too bad you can't have I mean that
I think that is why Trump want is he was
like I'm going to have fun in the
political space and everyone's like you
can't do that and he's like watch yeah
and then you vote for the fun guy yeah I
mean I don't he has too much fun don't
get me wrong
ah I'll overturn democracy he has fun
yeah it's fun it's fun undeniable what
if yeah what if we perpetuate fraud well
here's what oh whoa don't do that dog
that's 15 yard penalty that's a 15 yba
player oh that's a good question yo
that's a good question who is the
hottest NBA
player Kelly UB Jr's handsome as
[__] there's names I can't think of
right
now yeah I'm thinking it's not Devon
Booker he's not doing it for me no
Steph's like husband hot but he's not
like sexy boy Steph is a husband yeah
yeah that's not a guy that you like yeah
did you see him get the hole in one in
Tahoe at the proam oh he's incredible
everything he's so sick dude incredible
I was just like his life is made of
magic and joy to watch my wife and I
were watching the Beckham documentary
that guy was a [__] he was sex he was
maybe the hottest guy ever yeah he's
insane once he shaved the head with the
hair it was weird with the hair it was
fine whatever when he shaved the head
you're like dude I'll [__] you that's
the real Mark of like a true hot dude is
like four different hairstyles that all
just send you to brickville like when
Brad Pit is like I'm going to go long
hair I'm going to go blonde hair and
then shave really is the moment when
everyone goes oh [__] like like like
Brad Brad Pitt and Fight Club is just
that's about that's
that's M form for me we know the be you
know what I mean first rule of Fight
Club is don't tell anyone I'm sucking
your dick bro
oh who's down love having rules oh the
Tyler badish is down the cowboy starting
center is down so that's good for uh
that's yeah that's not great oh it's not
when you do that Jesus [__] oh [__] oh
[__] that that is the thing that I hate
the most about football is those
injuries they are unavoidable they're
facing the other way they're planted a
dude just falls on your leg it folds up
like a
chair God damn dude that is not fun he
got off on oh no that was it's a rookie
that is a new guy that is some fresh eye
black folks he definitely dressed like
he didn't think he was going to play he
was dressing for Instagram picks and I
admire that about him but now he's going
to see some snaps and you can feel his
sphincter tight and he's actually
walking yeah this is a nightmare 14
nothing one first down have we had one
first
down I don't know if we've had one first
down
I'm trying to remember what it would
have looked like and I can't think about
it I'm still trying to think of who the
hottest NBA player is to be honest Kawai
can suck a big
dick all right there you go you
go we didn't get the first still Cooks
this was like the ninth year in a row
that people were like Cooks could be an
interesting fantasy option this year he
might finally be a going to average 7.2
points he ends up being un do you play
Fantasy at all I don't really I I only
do prize picks that's why I'm glad I'm
working with them cuz I can't fantasy is
too much commitment every week I got to
yeah I'm in four leagues it's too many
leagues all right here we go first down
there you go hey this game is turning
this game is turning around oh this is
why I was asking about the Niner Super
Bowl again I'm old enough to remember ya
went up like 21 nothing in the first
quarter and the Cowboys still lost but
they clawed back and it was a very like
I look back on that game mostly fondly
and maybe this will be like that Clinton
just said I'm dressed like a floating
head which I didn't know we were black
look no it was a little warm in here I
came prepared I mean I have the we can
do this yeah yeah as long as the audio
is good who
cares Jay Victory asked if about get rid
of Dak I would not because who are you
going to replace him with that's the
issue if you have an above average QB
you can't get rid of them you just can't
yeah it's everyone wants like one of
four guys and they're like why don't I
have that guy because no team's gonna
get rid of him that is actually the
genius of Shanahan is you're still good
with any quarterback and there's no that
you guys in the Dolphins same offensive
mind essentially it's the only team that
are like that it's it's painful to look
back on it because there's a lot of like
wood ifs with the Trey lance thing all
the stuff that we gave up for that and
we didn't necessarily need it but we
would have never ended up with Brock
randomly yeah he would have it's a it's
a funny alternate universe because if we
didn't waste all those picks and then
realize that he's not the guy we
probably don't pick him last he doesn't
get this opportunity anywhere else he
could have just not had an NFL career I
mean like he he would have been a
practice squad backup quarterback and
that's a great salary or whatever but
there are zero other situations in the
league where he actually finds his way
absolutely onto the field and now he
could be playing on the biggest stage
and he wouldn't be good on the other
teams because I not even making fun of
him right now the other teams don't have
a Supporting Cast that would allow him
to be good right what's up
someone just called you handsome as [__]
it's both yall for answer and oh
perfect perfect would you get rid of D
oh yeah I yeah that's what I was saying
I would not get rid of Dak because he's
above average so if he's not yeah yeah
Kev if somebody gives money let me know
cuz I got to acknowledge them cuz I want
money I'm not going to say I'm poor
that's a lie but I want I can see the
Empire State Building from this window
but I want your money so I can keep
paying for the view that's what I
want so guys if you want to you know 30
fantasy leagues that can't be true
someone said they're in 30 fantasy
leagues I think that's J Victory it's
probably a uh probably an embellishment
but it gets out of hand quick because I
have a hard time I like being part of a
fun group chat so I'm in four leagues
which is too many two or three is is
better how do you still like the group I
I hate the group chats I because they
get spicy it has to be the right group
chat you got to have people saying some
wild stuff it's fun sometimes you you
stop doing it and sometimes you do
Brandon we're gonna watch the Eagles
game together that's Brandon Carpenter
he's one of my earliest fans and he's
from Philly and he's um oh you gotta do
that he's not a piece of [__] to me but
he is a piece of [__] just cuz he's from
Philly um but yeah we're going to he
keep keeps telling me five and out
you're still not going to win a Super
Bowl but I don't feel confident enough
about that to say it more than this but
you're not it's going to fall apart it
just is I don't know what else to tell
you you can't stay this healthy forever
I all of last year I
was I didn't believe in the Eagles all
of last year and I bet against them
pretty much every week and and I lost
pretty much every week I was like I
don't believe and then I was like okay
they're getting overvalued and I pretty
much never fell off and they went all
the way to the Super Bowl I'm pleased to
say I am back this year and I'm like no
I'm like I'm going to stay on it
actually I did bet on them today and
they covered uh but I don't I just
really think if we can stay healthy
we're a better team I actually do think
that and I think Jaylen Herz he can't
dude you can't run a quarterback that
often no matter how big he is and he
just stays upright yeah all the time
it's just not going to happen oh God
damn those linebackers
hit [__] it would be so if you could
play Brandon talking [__] dude he said
Avery's delusional about these Niners
yeah I don't think I might I might be
delusional about the Eagles but I'm not
delusional about the ners the Niners are
a great team here's the thing you can't
reason with these people they're animals
yeah I'm an animal too we're not we're
just yelling I had an Eagles fan that
was at my I said my wife was from Philly
I had an Eagles fan that was at my house
this morning drunk drove to Philly so he
could watch the Eagles game and it was
11:00 a.m. and it's a 2-hour drive and
the Eagles game was at 4 p.m. that is
amazing they're just so stupid they
can't do the math yeah but that's what
makes it a great Sports Town yeah that
is that's what you want dude you just
want a bunch of
soldiers yeah yeah uh I can't watch flr
and I'm not bro enough Anna watch
flagrant dude we love female fans
they're the best I'm built like a woman
you know what I mean that's got to be
you gotdamn hips yeah dude I'm saying I
mean I'm giv him birth soon child
rearing
tush we love the female fans come
through great teams always choke that
does make any sense uh do you think the
Chiefs do it again oh Bish is back in I
let's go yeah I mean I don't know I'm
very I I don't say this a lot cuz
usually I'm just afraid but I'm pretty
bullish on uhoh oh there you
go that was in the middle of me saying
we're going to win the Super Bowl this
year but uh let's go brand suck my dick
cornerbacks are going to be the
thing coverage celebrating my bad
Brandon my bad dude sorry go no no no
that no
that's so this guy kavante Turpin is
this supposed to be this huge playmaker
this is the first play I've ever seen
him successfully make and not [__]
ruin that was nasty as soon as I thought
saw the balls going to nine I got scared
and yeah you did you were Afra I mean he
looked like he was about to fall over
yeah but that was a very athletic
play not great for the field goals over
under but still oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I literally never PR or the de i'
literally never won a prize pick I would
Bey happy to lose on yeah definitely
fade me for sure fade me but I you get I
I always make two picks so I'll usually
get one and lose one so fading me
probably won't work the way I don't know
how you have to do it but the way that I
found success with betting is I usually
just bet spreads but I'll just pick 10
games and I'll bet them all individually
instead of trying to like Loop parlays
and like get everything and then I'll
usually go like six and four sometimes
I'll go eight and two sometimes you but
like you have to bet on a lot of things
cuz if you just on a couple you might
lose all of them and then you then hurts
your feelings yeah that's a good point
yeah so you got to gamble more how
gambling addictions start Yeah the more
and more money and
the play the odds I go small amounts of
money but I spread it out you know I
just bet cuz I'm a competitor it does
fun it yeah it does make the game more
fun I want to see how many yard I'm very
curious how many yards whoever gets it
what happened Clinton's been hating on
my head but he he's finally coming
around
you know it's funny cuz I saw that and I
was like go it's great he said you were
funny notic it that's all we care about
dude we're such [__]
idiots uh this is I mean it's commercial
Dame going to the Bucks oh I love it and
I'm not as worried about them losing
Drew holiday as everybody else yeah cuz
he got cooked by Jimmy Butler and maybe
that was just one bad Series yeah but
Dam and Yannis is crazy and I think you
can get defensive players I was going to
say that's what they're going to need to
figure out um from my understanding I'm
not as deeply versed in basketball I'm
like a homer I'm a Warriors fan so I see
everything through that prism I'm just
excited because it's another fun the NBA
is the king of storylines like even for
someone who doesn't know I can't
identify a zone defense you know I'm not
like I don't got it like that but I know
with at least like seven teams the drama
o i watch James Harden on Philly you
heard other drama that he was going to
go to Houston and they were going to
give him a Max contct and said he wanted
to be the scoring and they were like no
we're not doing that bro learn how to to
lose that much money cuz you interviewed
wrong is crazy so funny though crazy so
it's so James Harden yeah and he's got
so many Max contracts who even cares
it's like he obviously he's James Harden
he doesn't have to win the interview but
it's like if you've ever done a single
interview you just go I'm a team player
but that was I just want to help the I
just want to help the team win so the
way I interpreted is that his way of
saying I'm going to get back in shape
I'm going to get back to the scoring
champ and it's the only way he saw the
game like there's nothing else to play
for right yeah that's what it is hey hey
big cev can you check on my phone to see
how much battery is left on there can
the IG live you did yeah I'll plug it in
how many people were in it I don't know
total we can look at ins but it was like
no like yeah you total that' be great
yeah total I'm not sure
shows Jo Joey um oh Joey this is It's a
woman asking so we can't entertain that
but Joy's getting hit on that yeah love
that Joy's getting hit on stop [__]
head dude respect though yeah dude
Squidward's house dud stay hitting on me
it's so funny so many dudes are like a
go handsome never happens from a girl
and I'm okay with that I prefer it that
way yeah it's it's a lot easier it's e a
lot easier to turn down yeah it's easy
to not [__] you're like I mean you
you go God Dam no no no no no you go to
24 hour Fitness dog damn you work lats
damn no no no I can't do that I'm
married what are you bench
though oh son of a
f eat him up Brock can Michael Parson's
just get to Brock party
once just once not really dude his feet
are too fast he's got those quick
feet oh [__] why does this guy look like
a wased up Power Ranger
it's a great question that's a great
question it's kind of exactly what I'm
going for God it's so good dude there's
Ed yeah love big Lisa ripping some white
wine oh I heard Lisa mcaffry on an
interview in in Dallas and she was
hilarious like just a random sced
interview they didn't know it was her
and she was so funny yeah I have a
feeling they're just an elite crew
through and through
yeah who's his
brother Christians yeah yeah Muslim I
think his brother Christian Muslim and
Jewish
Muslim Muslim and Jewish AR kind of
they're they're fighting it out right
now so we just got Christian tonight
musl naming your son Christian as like
OD it's like bro we you just see I mean
we get it yeah he he drops like every IG
post he drops Bible verses I he he takes
it to Heart Christian dude you that's oh
also speaking of names at FBO Samuel
is that his is that there's no way no
it's not actually yeah he is well who
said who said Brock can't throw it deep
he out threw everyone in
red that can't be on him it's so no no
that was it was a whenever yeah whenever
it looks like a quarterback just had a
brain aneurysm it's for sure a broken
off Route or
miscommunication sorry hold on oh is no
intentional grounding he's just such a
bad
quarterback he didn't mean to do that
non special needs kid will get the hat
trick I think so I would love that to go
from a four touchdown mcaffrey week to
uh nons special needs
KD not George KD non special needs K
damn chat you funny yo there you go B
rup jumping
in b r hey I know you that's always do
that note to really will bring it on lay
it on thick thanks dog miss you let's
get these watches bro oh oh God no that
was
nasty Brock don't do that to our boy
come on not roughness yo that's not
don't do that to Christian please sit
him down for a moment that's not
roughness do that to the franchise
Brock there's no way that's roughing
that's that's
roughness I would rather lose this game
by 40 than lose yeah if he was Christi
you're
[__] I thought he was going to be
paralyzed
why do I look like Buzz Lightyear in his
frat boy days you mean Buzz Lightyear
dude what was the UN Sportsman like
conduct
for this is the second penalty on third
down God D he kind of lets him down soft
which I like his arms did that thing but
no it's
okay when they straighten out is when
it's [__] up
yeah yeah that was great coverage too he
ruined [__] great
coverage oh it's taunt oh well get the
[__] out of here dude he's I there's
nonsense penalties that was the penalty
not well that and hit okay cuz the
helmet helmet yeah but the that that
wasn't I think I think he was swatting
the ball out either that or he was
grabbing a little sack I thought just
yeah let's go ahead and just give it to
the guy who just suffered a light
concussion and get his head slammed on
the
ground do that's what I'm saying he
won't this usage won't last I I that's
the thing that's killing me about Kyle
and and Niners fans were up in arms last
year when all of our quarterbacks got
hurt and people start it's kind of hard
cuz it's football but you get a lot of
skill position guys hurt people try to
figure out is it Kyle's fault he uses
Christian a lot dude we have Elijah
Mitchell who gets hurt but he's good
it's a lot of a lot of usage for
Christian do you remember that well I
mean obviously you remember the chief's
ner Super Bowl how did you feel about
him passing and having that when it got
swatted oh [__] come on this is a
first down a first down and that's why
that's why what I was saying is you got
to use Christian every play as soon as I
saw how free everyone got and I saw and
I saw Christian I was like a this is a
son of a [__] it does sometimes look
aash kind of looks like an indifferent
llama I do though Chad is cooking
tonight oh my god dude the roast of us
is going
well oh yo Jeremy uh humpert Humber
keeps asking about the Lions I love we
will discuss the Lions I love the Lions
I love Dan Campbell I I think they're
going to be better than the Niners next
year and Eagles Brandon suck my dick you
think they're going to be better ooh
there we go I wonder wonder where Elijah
Mitchell is but that was Mason I think
yeah um they're great and I'm happy for
them I think almost everyone obviously
unless you're playing the Lions or
you're in their division or something
they've been so bad for so long and
Detroit fans seem like a good fan base
when you give them something they live
in Detroit God bless you got to get
something you know have something I did
a I did a club in Detroit a couple
weekends ago and all I knew about
Detroit was the sports and I was like
there's got to be more to it than sports
like I more cultured than that I get to
the club it's across from for field and
Co and it's inside of a Red Wings bar in
restaurant I was like all right this is
it this is all we got and it's it's Ford
and sports yeah that was it and GM
that's it this is the whole
city Jeremy we're talking about the
Lions how bad is the LI they're fun I I
also like the Redemption Arc of Dan
Campbell because someone mentioned the
the bite the kneecaps comment initially
everyone was like this guy's a
psychopath why did they even pick him
this is not X's and O's football and
then it's like no he's actually he is
inspiring them it is cool that he does
push-ups with them it's awesome did you
watch Hard Knock yeah I did that one
yeah it's great I would not mind if they
beat the Cowboys honestly I would mind
if they beat the ners see this is the
[__] thing is stupid [__]
penalties on third down I'm pretty sure
have gotten you two touchdowns yeah oh
you're just you're simply an
undisciplined group of
hooligans unbelievable
dude uh shows in New York soon yes I'm
doing my first headlining gig in New
York November 11th at City Winery oh
[__] yo check that out no but that's the
girl has been hitting on you so try not
to [__] this guy when you're at the show
Jen oh yeah can't [__] me but I'm
married but you're welcome to come to
the show it will be a great show that's
the only coming you're doing
88 on the Cowboys is CD lamb it's always
their best receiver that's not he didn't
get in oh come on
bro come on my sweet boy
Christian look at pops two rings there
he is there's mom she's getting blasted
off some Shard it's nothing like a
little Shard drunk in Santa Clara
California let me tell you I do it a lot
oh God damn it dude what's the flag hold
has there been a single penalty on the n
oh wait is that during the play feels
like
after that's a touchdown Jesus that is
that'll bend you
over what's the
flag
what are they talking
about was it before the touchdown or oh
well that looks like
it yeah dude they're going to get the
camera guy camera guy is like get off me
bro this is Elite
equipment yeah
dude oh should get ejected y don't you
touch auk like that though they really
threw it on 65 though they're going to
go after him yeah they did he should get
ejected he didn't yeah it's always the
guy who retaliates I've heard it a
thousand times but that is what happens
but you can't let dudes push around your
slot receiver yeah I know but also
[__] I hate the Niners so
much you don't deserve a good football
team I think we do no you don't you're
just such cucks and I love that you have
to root for magga Jo and Nick Bosa I
love him dude yeah but you know that fan
base just they root for him and then
they go [__] hate every conservative
on Earth well it's funny cuz it breaks
out every like like once a year during
the off season some like tweet thing
will get going in Niners circles about
like Bosa stuff and then he doesn't say
anything and then he plays well and it's
like yeah good it's football what do we
think we're going to agree with all
these guys politics yeah I know I agree
but you guys are cucks that's the thing
you're just the ciest C in the world
yeah I mean I I don't think this is
going to make you like it anymore but
since they moved that Stadium all the
way down to Santa Clara which is more it
is more of like the tech it's it's
probably more conservative there than
you'd think at that game not that it is
conservative compared social okay yes I
went to the I told you I went to the
Clemson game on Saturday this this was
new they hit uh a full God Bless America
a full national anthem military fly over
this is all normal they hit a prayer
okay we're in the South they hit a
pledge of allegiance to the
flag I had not done that since I was in
second grade dude I was I I repg I
hadn't pledged in a long time I'm back
they got under the flag yeah dude they
got to remind you and God that was wild
dude one nation under God [__] yo go
Tigers God that's so
funny oh my God they people were so nice
they didn't even sell alcohol in the
stadium this dude I was in the Wake for
Section I mentioned and uh this a guy
Clemson guy like leans down and looks at
us I'm like oh he's about to start
talking [__] and he just goes hi welcome
to Clemson I was like oh that's sweet
that's great yeah it was lovely Clemson
had a run dude they did and now that
it's over people are turning up the heat
on Dabo I mean they're like he only he
he's nothing without his assistance and
all this stuff and who was that
defensive coordinator he had that was
nasty he's a Oklahoma's coach I think
venables yes yeah yeah yeah I just
remember the name it was a fire name
venables I love when people go oh
they're nothing without the assistance
it's like Oh you mean they're the head
of the org that hired really good people
to help the team and now you're mad at
them that they hired good people who got
what are we doing very true that's what
I'm hoping the cases with Nick serani to
be honest with you cuz he lost both of
his coordinators last year
yeah okay I'm so Joey's the [__] yeah
that PL of legance got him dude yeah
dude I'm back under the flag feels good
maybe we'll have to rip one off at half
time rip a pledge I'm so down actually
yeah at halftime we're going to do
pledge of and then we're going to do a
pledge of allegiance put the flag on the
screen yeah that'll be nice sick dude
[__]
yeah somebody said I
bet comes in him the energy would be
different than Joey's experience hey
make me some Masala hey hey get out of
Clans no I was actually I was I was with
a very diverse group I was sitting
between the uh me I was sitting two two
two Mexican parents I was sitting
between the parents of the uh and the
punter at Wake
[Laughter]
Forest that is really the best of course
I just now put together that they were
Mexican cuz they they can kick soccer
players yeah of course yeah I just
that's the only way Mexicans are get
into the league really all right we got
a five you got to go back to Boston dog
oh [__] yeah dude The Wilbur is one of
the best comedy experiences in my life
second to shooting the special but it
was amazing that sounds incredible I
love the Wilbur I for me I didn't ever
perform there until I headlined I didn't
do that necessarily on purpose but I'm
soad happened and then you got to exp
that's really really cool it was really
[__] cool but I'll be laugh Boston
December 10th folks go see my man I'm
not going to be there I came already
this
year uh
oh throwing finger
issue
what the absolute [__] a little off
there how has par been this year I know
there's a lot of hype going into it it
was like he's going to you know they're
going to be better with just Him in the
Le I Zeke was Zeke was done Rico D is
better than Zeke Tony Pard is not I
think he's better as a change up back
than a lead back but they're still
better than they were with Zeke for sure
I mean Zeke was so cooked he's cooked on
the the Patriots too yeah the Patriots
are cooked my God I thought they were
going to be back this game I thought cuz
they look they look decent against the
Eagles they look decent against the
Dolphins who are very good teams and now
theyve just falling apart against the
Saints I love watching you br oh [__]
come on is that
wo that was a two- yard pass on Third
and five if you're not going to go for
it why would you do
that yo where can we catch Joey near
Sacramento uh I in the G in the gay bay
I will be uh at the San Jose Improv
December
20th um very excited for that I did that
the kind of like Christmas show there
last year was my first time doing that
biggest sellout that I've had that
that'll be a fun I've heard San Jose is
a great comedy audience actually I'm
doing the San Jose Improv at some point
by the way so you plug your dates and
then we'll look up mine yeah December
10th um is when I'll be it's the Improv
is fun cuz what it is is it's like it's
a club but it's in an old theater but
it's like a wellb built theater so it
feels like a theater but it's still
small enough that you can get the like
you can talk to them like it's a club
you don't have to just perform like it's
conversational but you can get up into a
second deck you can put like 480 in
there I need I've heard and I've heard
San Jose is a great comedy audience yeah
it you just get you get it it is it's a
very diverse town you get people with
different beliefs different backgrounds
different socioeconomic status they're
smart and diverse yeah that's what you
want that's the best that's what you
want hey Kev is my phone um up and
running or is it
dead
it's they're picking up on the sexual
attention we've discussed the casting
couch is happening 100% yeah I'm G to
[__] Joey I don't know why it's even
weird um did vaa text that he's coming
at all do you know um I haven't seen
anything from him now you know my phone
code right I won't say it CU I'm
streaming but that [__] is there you
know it that's how you know I'm faithful
you know what I mean everybody got my
phone password I love that dude holess
out here as it should be
Hess I've never been so happy to be a
Pat's hater they are officially yeah a
lot of people are happy this year
they've been waiting for this for a long
time Joey say hi to Holly son girl
[__] is getting at you no that's my
friend and he's asking me to say hi to
my
wife shout out Doug you sent that to AOS
you can just Veno me next
time hey Doug I like you dude I like the
way you operate Doug's the man he
officiated my wedding I've known him
since we were like eight he's he's the
best he funnier than me actually but
he's too much of a [__] to stand on it
oh [__] no I'm kidding he's the Doug if
you want to come to my show I'll give
you time instead of Joey I mean Joey's
headlin he don't need it anyway but come
I'll let you open for me and but don't
ever perform for Joey when you figure
out the San Jose dates let me know
because if I'm home it would be fun to
come through dude those be very fun I
was going to do my special there
actually have been a cool spot another
comedian was like yeah go bigger and
then I didn't so I think I don't know if
we chose new dates or not but um I was
supposed to I I want to do that it's a
great market for you to hit either way
you'll do very well
there Brandon Carpenter said he's going
to bed Aver your crowd workor is amazing
your team isn't that's a sweet that's a
sweet way to I'll take that I'll take
that Brandon Brandon's a sweet guy dude
he's probably trash cuz he's from Philly
but he's a sweet guy probably a human
sack of [__] cuz he's from Philly but
he's a sweet guy in 30 seconds why you
going to bed so early
Brandon that's the thing so I just moved
to New York from California for people
who don't know I'm adjusting to the east
coast viewing schedule very different
not used to games being on this late oh
dude I'm it blows my mind I doesn't make
any sense to me that Sunday night
football starts at 400 p.m. or whatever
dude it starts at 5: yeah it's lovely
cuz you have that you wake up at 10: the
games are on so the games are just kind
of simmering all day it leads up to the
Sunday Night Football and then after
that you can watch a show or something
you have dinner it's but it doesn't make
sense to me that's Sunday Night Football
yeah the pregame for Sunday Night
Football is at broad daylight yeah well
it's wild to me that you people stay out
this [__] late yeah I know I don't
like this viewing schedule yeah I mean
we sleep late because we're Comics but I
still as I was going to say as a comic I
kind of like it cuz if I can get back
from a show and I'm like oh a game's on
and I can kind of just have that on
while like wind down or whatever but
it's it's very it's very odd that if you
really care about it you have to stay up
to an ungodly hour for people who have
to work at 8:00
a.m. I'm beginning to think uh I'm
beginning to worry this is going to
really get away from the Cowboys if they
if the ners score here it's a real
[__] problem it would not be looking
great swarming dude we're going to have
to find other things to do soon I mean
the pledge Allegiance that's going to
happen that that's big that'll take
seconds yeah that'll eat up a nice 12
seconds it's a quick
pledge 30 seconds Max yeah yeah it's a
quick
one [__]
me this is a terrible inaugural game for
the stream I love it I think it's great
we're going to do we we'll start doing
this on my channel uh we're only going
to do ners games from here on out and
you work for me now dog I didn't think
about it when I was started streaming
footb I live
here buddy this couch folds out we [__]
we'll have a fun time uh I didn't think
about doing the cow Cowboys just seem
like a fun thing to me I didn't think
about them losing and me just having to
sit here well you should have thought
about that do you watch a game the whole
game even if your team is getting
crushed uh I will I will not surrender
to having it on but like I'll probably
start like well I could start working on
a clip or something like that turn this
[__] off yeah I always leave it on cuz
then I'll be I'll try to talk myself
into the fact that I'm like gaining
important fan knowledge I'll be like oh
is that the tight end that we got
from I was state but I think it's just
because uh Sports make me feel uh not
alone in the world that constantly
reminds you that you truly are wow that
was a big [__] heavy sentence and the
you would think you're a Cowboy
fan no we're vibing somebody just said
that hust Minaj jumped off a bridge
that's tragic
but at least now he'll have something to
write about in next
show I was going to say he jumped off
the rhetorical bridge for sure
I oh my God
huh yeah yeah I heard it dude that's
crazy word no what did Bill marah say
dude I did you hear the news that hussen
uh Hamas attacked hussen and killed
6 did you hear that that's be [__] up
man that's terrible thing man terrible
thing has
happened yo I'm going to get you
something to drink after this we got I
think we got like a little Cokes and
[__] in there if you want one I drink
Zia cuz I'm trying to be less fat than I
was uh I'm good I'm good with the
water what what did Bill Mah say oh he
just went at him oh at Hassan or
J there you go all right they didn't
score there and the Cowboys are probably
not going to score here but that's fine
if they get three if they can turn this
into three yeah that's a that's I mean
this should be big for your prize pick
yeah oh that would be big for my this
would be this would be big for the prize
pick Trey's getting tre's getting loose
handing Dak the ball Trey looks great
with the earpiece in that's one of the
things that I admire dude Trey Lance is
a [__] goodlook looks like he'd be
great he great throwing motion the ball
comes out with a laser he looks sexy in
the uniform he's he's working on the
hairline I think so he's got to tighten
up but um he he's Oh I thought we were
in Europe that was not helpful for the
field goal thing um oh Jesus no if they
can turn this they got with 50 seconds
two timeouts yeah if they can turn that
into a field goal just get some momentum
going
offensively who are your favorite active
comedians well I think the most active
comedian if you just look at body type
is probably Matt rif oh yeah um no uh I
would I mean obviously obviously uh I
mean you kind of have to start with like
Chappelle Burr like that's kind of where
I kick things off but um you guys
Schultz Shane you know Shane is a
monster man holy [__] what about you
same yeah yeah and then me yeah yeah I
said you
guys I just me you know I had to say it
yeah yeah yeah yeah no but it's Burr to
me it's the guy bur's the guy right now
and I think obviously Chappelle is like
probably probably the goat but right now
in this moment bur to me is the best
it's I think it's always the the what
you're really looking for and a special
that you're going to like tell everyone
to watch is as a comic you're watching
it you just go [__] that's dude how did
they God how did they get to that first
son one I didn't even think how did they
get to this first but when I saw Shane
gillis's bit about dating the Navy SEAL
oh yeah yeah I mean I was like how the
[__] did he get there that's
unbelievable I remember being like God
damn it's so good and his his George
Washington story we saw him working on
that too cuz we saw him like moon tower
Comedy Festival in Austin 2021 yeah
we're you know we're just coming out of
Co and he had dropped his YouTube
special and that was killing it but then
he's working on the new stuff and he had
both of those bits right out of the gate
and it was like holy [__] this next
special is going to be nuts dude you
know who love to run like Advanced like
if we could Mix Sports and comedy I'd
love to do like Advanced stats on Mark
Norman special yeah because the amount
of like incredible premises that he sets
up and knocks down is probably like 10
times more than anyone else he blows
through it so much that you're like
he'll say something he'll move on to the
next joke and then I'll be thinking
about the pre I'm like wait that was
profound and I'm like oh [__] I got to
get back up to the to the next one his
his jokes per minute level is is start
Joe list is great I love Joe list yeah
list is the is the best I never see it
coming wherever he whatever Direction he
takes it I don't see it coming um BL
somebody asked about Trevor Wallace
Trevor Wallace and Blau stiff socks
podcast Michael blow time blau's my
brother dude we came up together yeah me
blow and Schultz all came up together
that's amazing and I I love Trevor he
was one of like Schultz and Trevor were
the first two people to really like take
me out for for Road gigs so uh and
Trevor's the man too he's super super
fun just great there's a lot of like
people always talk about how like oh
comics are you know like better watch
yourself they're going to R you there's
a lot of like good fun sweet people
doing comedy right now I feel like yeah
who needs to oh no no he's out he is uh
J crazy that Fred is covering him our
linebackers covering him all the way
downi yeah uh jeni said she's going to
open for one of well either one of us in
three years I look forward to it yo but
just don't try to have sex with Joey
please yeah I was like open in what
way Will William Montgomery is wild he's
a fun dude which one is he he's uh uh W
wild looking redhaired kill Tony Austin
yeah have you been out to the Mother
Ship no I haven't yet it's it's a it's a
scene dude it's a fun it's a fun place
who's this that's down I you have a
player that's injured and I hope he's
really
good oh oh
it's that's not who's lying down though
but someone Jackson 95 hurs Bosa
Jesus thought that guy ran into Bosa now
he's hurt cuz he ran into a brick [__]
house he ran into a wall the same one
Bosa once built in
Mexico all right guys I'm going to pee
yeah you get loose it's not halftime we
gota wait till half time I pee I'm going
to get a little drink a drinky poo maybe
glass of water I'm going to get you a
glass of water you got that still yeah
you're still good on
that we can do we'll do a refresh dude
these guys who stream for months on end
like kaad how the [__] do they do that
yeah I don't know I don't it just
becomes what they do they're just
talking to you know this yeah I guess so
it becomes your social life and your job
you just do it constantly well I mean
you saw what happened to fuzy yeah fuzy
was trying the 24hour stream and then
lost his mind which is what happens when
you decide that interacting with cameras
just normal life 100% of the time it's a
very fun thing to do I've never watched
a game like this before and seems to be
good luck get him
exactly I just don't understand why he
keeps taking
sex he keeps extending plays not
athletes and they're not just they're
just not going to use a timeout I guess
they're just going to let the clock run
they don't want that smoke
dog
y yeah when when Greenlaw and Fred are
both at 100% that's a scary group this
is miserable this is the [__] love
that he's wearing fat
chains all right stream don't go
anywhere prize picks y you know you need
to go go on prize picks you there's
still Monday night games left more or
less for whoever's I don't even know
who's playing tomorrow I'm too
demoralized to know but use the codee
aosh when you sign up they'll match your
sign up bonus up to $100 so that's h100
free dollars if you want it you know
what I mean prize picks more or less
that's all you got to do just make your
make your pics um all right I'm going to
get you a water cool I'm going to go
pee Solo Cup you know what I mean keep
it you want water no you want to sit on
the stream for b no can you plug in my
phone so it don't die yeah all right
chat let's do this this is the casting
couch I'm going to do a 5 minute solo
jerk
and uh we'll see how long it
lasts put your life savings on Bears to
the Super Bowl that's a nice take nice
win against the
commanders uh this is a good question
over under on how long the pledge takes
I say we put it at 25 seconds um you
guys will have to figure out how to make
action amongst
yourselves uh Fallon asked uh Kim
Patterson yeah cam cam is the the man
love cam the whole crew in Austin is
great Cam's great Will's great uh Derek
Poston asod what is
this yeah yeah I can use
this do I feel like Austin is a [__]
hole besides the mothership I can really
go both ways on that cuz I like Austin I
used to like visiting Austin before
comedy took over like pre- comedy all
the venues in Austin that are now comedy
which is great for us were like live
music shows and I thought that was a
really unique and interesting thing that
felt different from other places kind of
before it got super discovered um but
there is a lot of fun awesome energy now
and it is cool uh do I feel like it's a
[__] hole besides the mothership it's a
fun town I enjoy it uh but after about a
week there I'm always like yeah I'm
good when I was leaving California which
I will eventually go back to I was like
I think New York is going to be more
sustainable as a as a city to be in
constantly even though I'm defly afraid
of the cold cuz I'm a big old
puss over under Ram Super Bowl not going
to [__] happen
um how big is my Kyle Written House
poster do you see that what does this
say dog San
Francisco it's not big it's a small it's
a it's a little I keep him in a locket I
wear a little heart-shaped locket with
my boy Ry look he did kill a child
molester look we don't have to get into
all this uh pledge 13 seconds I believe
that
actually
um best bomb story actually so I was uh
this was one of the first times I did
comedy in New York and I didn't bomb per
se uh but it was during coid so I had to
do uh a show in a park and uh the
problem with doing a show in a park is
that homeless people live there and
you're on their Turf uh which is
horrifying and a homeless dude decided
to actually attack me during my set so
it wasn't exactly a bomb but he tried to
hit me uh and we had to have like a
whole group of like New Yorkers surround
me and this Puerto Rican chick just
screamed at him and told him he was a
[__] loser till he went
away this Austin this was New York
actually we back um am I my mic is on I
I turned my mic off to PE and then I
couldn't figure how to turn it back on
so okay is the flag up can we get the
flag up and run oh yeah that's right do
you think we have all the um I know this
it's not even [__] question okay do
well yeah they made they probably made
you do it on yeah on yeah every day you
do this every day we did it every we
kind of stopped at one point yeah it's
California I think once we hit fifth
grade we would just have group sex fifth
grade unbelievable ready on three 2 3 I
pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all Now suck this dick suck
this R blue dick come on dog come on get
out of here that was tight that did feel
about 13 seconds yeah I didn't uh I
actually didn't time that but someone
someone called that and that feels
relatively accurate to me everybody does
it with the same Cadence that's the
Cadence yeah it's like a song you know
it's just it's it's locked in it felt
good to do it again
man yo I'm if the USA bombs India whose
side am I
on who side is going to win let's just
be honest about
that it was 17 seconds we were
timed hey Kev is is it possible to plug
my phone in big guy and get that IG live
running we're going to go to ig live
juice the numbers you know love
that the USA bombs how many people are
in this online right now watching us
Kev like 100 like 3300 so far that's not
bad not bad at all I'll take the Jets
dude I don't know what to do with that
team I think are are the Chiefs showing
signs of weakness the fact that they
barely beat the Zach will oh no yeah
Kelsey got hurt oh I didn't see com back
in though
oh that looks a little as a man who tore
his Achilles this year that looked a
little SC oh he comes back in so he's
fine he got a quick VX yeah yeah yeah
dude how funny was Aaron Rogers calling
him call Mr
fizer Aaron Rogers is he's entertaining
he's deeply in his own anus but it's
really entertaining yeah it's also the
Jets are owned by the [__] Johnson
family who made a
vaccine you know what I mean
wait that's hilarious yeah you're
calling him Mr fizer and your boss is Mr
Johnson that is crazy I mean I
just do you think he's going to be able
to so he he believes he's going to come
back through obviously he's got Cutting
Edge science but he also believes I saw
his quote he believes in the power of
prayer and intention and he's doing
those and I'm not [__] on that uh
yeah it's all well and good yeah but do
you uh do you think he's gonna be able
to come back quicker from yeah no no
chance I mean apparently he's already
like kind of walking which is crazy but
I just you're playing football it's it's
dangerous dude I I so I tore my achilles
in February I got out of a boot and I
and I retor it I tore it twice this year
so that [__] can happen I thought it was
a different legs well now we're getting
really into my medical history cuz two
years ago boot on his foot for for a
long time I broke my left ankle and then
it healed and one year later I tore my
right Achilles and then and then I tore
that again Jesus Christ yeah but that
one kind of functioned as one long
injury that was just back in the boot
that's awful yeah but I'm a I'm I'm a
[__] athlete that's the point
chat don't ever don't ever [__] on
Squidward moves yo not a good foundation
on Squidward's house dude I gotta be
honest no dude yo we build from the top
down I start with I invest my Foundation
is my haircut and everything else flows
from underneath that the George K
haircut yeah
dude hey are we on IG live Kev hell yeah
dude hell yeah IG take this [__] to
YouTube it's got higher production value
believe it or not yeah we're live all
over the place there's a [__] running
score count you know what I mean
whatever you call it a fox box a ticker
yeah and you can talk to us cuz we can't
we can't interact with IG live right now
that's true I can't see your comments on
my phone that [__] is facing this way
but ultimately uh who do you think's
going to
win
oh yeah the Cowboys are losing very
badly and I didn't think about this when
I decided to scream Cowboys games that
they're always going to break my heart
and I'm going to die never seeing
another Super Bowl I forgot to do that I
forgot to think about that yeah I really
thought they could do it this year I
still haven't fully given up but it's
but that's the nature of Cowboys fans
it's the whole off seon everyone kind of
the the engine gets rolling it's it's
like the Lakers cuz ESPN there's a
vested interest get it pumping that's
what people want to hear about true
you have to have a take and so
inevitably 50% of the people are going
to be like I don't know I think you know
the team's looking different this year I
was in training camp I was talking to
McCarthy even he's lost some weight you
know they always [__] start spinning
this [__] up and then inevitably you go
to the playoffs and and 5 minutes after
the game there's a video of a bunch of
people in Dallas breaking their TVs yeah
that's the life I don't normally do that
I I think they'll be good I never think
I I never think Super Bowl this year I
thought Super Bowl not never very rarely
yeah this year I thought that cuz it
just makes sense the defense is good the
quarterback is good enough I thought
this doesn't seem to be the case though
well I just think that our team makes a
lot of teams look look bad no that's
possible that's possible I when do you
play the Eagles uh I don't even know if
we do I think we do though I think you
do I might stream that game that might
be a game we're streaming it'll be a
Sunday night for sure yeah I I do love
obviously it depends on who's playing
but for some reason Sunday night
football is always the best game of the
week well now more than Monday night of
course yeah Monday Night Football when I
was a kid dude it used to be the thing
and I feel like it's not anymore
December
3rd Eagles or Niners at
Eagles I got to say this about Philly
they have a very real HomeField
Advantage especially in the playoffs
that's going to be appointment viewing
that's going to be very fun I mean of
course football but that's going to be
great that's going to determine one seed
yeah feels like it who gets the bye I
meanless it's always bye in San
Francisco
baby you're not going to win the Super
Bowl come on guys your quarterback is
Brock I was just making a gay joke but
yeah okay okay okay all right okay no
that's good that was good dude I didn't
get it thank you yeah uh Brock Super
Bowl MVP I mean some people are saying
it no one has ever said started it right
here ever said it possible yeah he
wouldn't get it it would be be Christian
yeah he's also not going to stay healthy
this is the thing I just these other
teams can't stay healthy that's all I
keep banking on Brock is a spry young
man dak's finger exploded this game
Christian mcaffry I'm talking about oh
yeah no he'll be good yeah but if Dak
gets hurt it's you know he not the
biggest loss I would support like if if
we found a way to like get around drug
testing and we could pump him with like
hga like whatever the thing is that
makes you recover hella fast yeah I
would do that for Michael Parsons yeah I
would do that every team should get one
player that they can use some of that
alien juice on yeah you know you just
pick one guy I mean if you've seen Bosa
walking around without pads freak it
doesn't look humanly possible well
here's what's also interesting about B
of those his brother gets hurt a lot
yeah that's why I assumed he kind of
would and he did his second year or
whatever after you all lost to the
Chiefs but his brother is a Joey and as
we've discussed Joy have a poor found Jo
get hurt yeah just kind of what it
is a would you be surprised if J if I
found out that Jerry Jones was a clan
member I mean he did like at least it
would be interesting you know what I
mean I feel like there's it just that
would be the first time he's ever been
to the hood a
billion yeah a billionaire oh the Cam's
going to go off for a second guys
stream's going to go out but don't go
anywhere we're going to come back we're
just
SW
sancisco um I did Atlanta yeah I did a
few those were really fun what was your
uh joke your
premise uh no are you thinking of the
you're thinking of inside jokes no I did
dropping in when he when he was on the
road you know he came what did he do in
San Francisco we sex with a man yeah
that's right and and it was me he wanted
to oh no no sorry no he had he he paid a
black guy to have sex with his
girlfriend at the time yeah yep that was
it yeah no we drove her it was actually
equally gay we went to a gay bar and we
uh F yeah it was really fun and we we
drove these little like yellow like
go-karts around town it was fun it was a
good time and then in Atlanta we drove
tanks oh that's sick it was funny cuz
the premise of that show initially was
like go around and like see the town you
know and then we get to Atlanta I was
like o I guess we're going to see what
Atlanta is all about and he's like nope
we're driving 4 hours out of town in an
Uber to drive tanks I was like all right
for sure it was tight it was tight I
went to a gun range in Vegas and that
[__] was sick yeah it's fun to do that
[__] you You' never do it in your you
wouldn't like wake up in your house in
New York and be like let me do something
zany no but when you're on the road it's
like yeah let's do something fun and
also guns are awesome they are tight
you're awesome dude yeah people who are
anti-gun just go shoot a gun that should
really be the whole that's why
Republicans are so pro gun they just
want you to shoot once and you'll be
like I get it yeah people will die but I
get it you I mean I get it at least
everyone does have the things that they
think are fun that they're like people
just have to die like I love drinking
but like you could make a really good
argument that it shouldn't be but it's
like come on dude we got to get hammered
with the
fellas yo has NFL have time gotten
considerably shorter to
you uh I I don't know cuz I just don't
really watch it I feel like I just this
might be why when it comes on I just go
on my phone I do other things and I'm
like oh the game's back it's like I'm
time
traveling who the AFC do you think takes
it this year uh how do you feel about
the Buffalo Bills
I'm like very tired of I want them to be
good but I'm very tired of believing in
them yeah I mean they they have weeks
where they look like this Juggernaut
that we've been envisioning and making
them out to be but they're just so
inconsistent and then they thin out I
mean like I had them today minus five
and a half against I mean don't go up
against the Jags in London my God oh God
oh
no that guy get destroyed
um
God
damn let's go I expect to see CD running
loose more often
yeah uh what were we talk oh yeah
AFC yeah it's it's wide open I mean the
bills could do it but it seems like they
just can't qu you just can't really
count on them they're hard to bet on
week to week they could beat the best
team in the league they could lose to a
team that's not that good the Chiefs
look a little bit weaker than I'd expect
but but it seems kind of silly to bet on
anyone but them that's exactly what I
think in the Super Bowl as well like
it's a Super Bowl yeah you're going to
it's going to come down I think that I
think the NFC is gonna is g to take the
Super Bowl this year but yeah Mahomes is
different yeah I went to uh the Steelers
Browns game cuz I was in Pittsburgh for
shows I like I want to go to the
Steelers stadium and my friend flew in
so I had like a buddy to go with and we
went and pregamed and it was amazing
what's the best live like game
experience you've been to Pros cuz
college is different yeah a drunk
20-year-olds like gu of course
um I mean Lambo is crazy oh I want to do
Lambo um I know uh I'm I'm friends with
Bach tiari who unfortunately had to get
surgery this year but one of the linemen
for the Packers oh he's good he's one of
the best linemen in the league yeah
great dude hilarious I worked with my
first job at a college I worked with his
uh younger brother oh wow and then uh he
would like share my clips and then he
came to he came to one of my shows when
I was like basically a like a few years
in like just a little bit above open
Miker and he just this like Giant
football player comes in and he's like
dude you're going to be amazing I was
like oh my God and then he's you know as
as as I've kind of kept going I started
going to Lambo once a year and I I do
shows out there um I did a show at
Skyline the club in Appleton I haven't
even heard of we did it it's in Appleton
Wisconsin we did it on a Monday night
and we met at l field cuz it was a day
after the game and a bunch of the
offensive linemen got on a party bus and
we drove out toon [__] sick dude yeah
it was
crazy uh but Lambo is is a is a unique
experience because it's like everything
that's cool about college football but
in a pro Stadium but you got to go in
September and that's the thing I usually
do I haven't been out there in the in
the winter um but the fans are rabid you
know it's it's the tallest building in
the city it's the whole it's like the
economy of the oh yeah of course yeah um
I don't even know is Lambo like what is
is that the city I don't even know Lambo
is the name of the field it's in Green
Bay well I mean yeah Green Bay sorry
Green Bay is that the name is it Green
Bay Wisconsin is Green Bay Wisconsin is
the city north as [__] it's basically
Canada I don't know it's small bro it's
small it's a tiny population um yeah
he's going to look it up but it's it's
just really cool cuz in NFL yeah 100k
100K for a football team that's Bonkers
do and the town owns the team there's
suburb yeah there's suburbs that are
bigger yeah Dallas that's why it's one
of the most it's one of the most unique
things in professional sports and it's
just so cool like it's a you the second
you get off the plane you're just like
itching to see the stadium it's it's all
that matters sorry Kev can you look up
the population of Edison New Jersey
because I feel like they could get a
cricket team at the very least like a
professional cricket team for sure
100,000 wow there you go dude bust out
the bats we can't get a few we can't get
a football team because it's it doesn't
the Market's not there but Cricket done
do you think there's a an angle for
Cricket in the US baseball is the same
it's so similar to baseball yeah I enjoy
it more obviously cuz I only watch the
World Cup and that's super high stakes
right which is about to start I think
it's starting this week uh but yeah that
it's never going to cuz baseball's yeah
and that's like I like I can try giving
other sports a chance like soccer and
rugby Cricket's a t and I'm a baseball
fan when I see it I'm like damn I gotta
I it takes a lot the knee pads throw me
off you know regular season baseball
sucks see I like it but for a different
reason to me regular season baseball is
like it's like a football is like a
concert regular season baseball is like
a podcast it comes on almost every day I
throw it on I'm a Giants fan I just put
the game on while I'm doing other work I
like just having it on it's it becomes
like a a daily part of life but yeah I
can't like tell someone who doesn't like
baseball sit down you got to watch this
mid June game yeah but playoff baseball
fun because the stakes and the tension
yeah and that's what Cricket is so one
team go bats first they get as many runs
as they can and then the next team bats
and then it's just the tension of and
then you're this is I joke this is why
Indians are so good at math cuz you're
constantly calculating how many balls
they have left and how many runs they
need and how much they need to average
and it's just like a constant thing and
it's it's fun because it's just super
the tension just keeps building and
building and the sless allows for The
Telecast to get these dramatic shots you
see the guy face probably yeah and and
then you start toward the end for
whatever reason I guess the ball gets
kind of worn down so they'll start
hitting more runs right so that's always
like well are they going to get the six
the Sixers app like oh that's a great
wrinkle you score more at the end cuz
the ball gets beat up yeah it just does
that's sick
yeah so by the end of that over what
what is it called the the gear turn that
bat it's like oh this is now it's just
run after run after run so now it's just
yeah it's fun that's fun all right I'll
have to get in I mean I can get into
anything World Cup India versus Pakistan
is uh October 14th if you find a way to
watch it yeah it'll be fun I was going
to go out there I don't think I'm going
to be able to but if you can so sick
even watching it on TV it's just so
tense how do you get out there you just
hop on the top of a
train
Yes actually if you can't get other
seats if you can't get us in the train
like you know one AC then yeah you got
to
do uh have you ever been to a playoff
hockey game no keep hearing that that's
a false start so yeah I grew up going to
sharks games cuz San Jose and uh that is
the coolest that is my favorite live
sporting experience is playoff hockey
really of course I love the team cuz you
know it means when it's like when you're
San Jose has one team that's 15 minutes
from my house it's like you know it
feels like it really belongs to us so we
love the Sharks and they tuck right now
but they're working hard um but just the
playoffs for oh do we hit our time limit
it's the yo Kev can you check the uh
this is that just the chat or we still
streaming okay guys shouts to Big cab by
the way he's streaming this whole thing
we can't see your chat anymore but he
may
go um oh [__] come on dog that was
actually a good
pass
God damn it this game is very
frustrating can't end soon enough
frankly son of a [__] dude um but yeah
playoff hockey is lit you should find a
way to a game the the energy is just
crazy do have you ever been to a live
hockey game never I've heard it's great
oh bro you got to go live playoff hockey
yo the Stars if they go to the playoffs
again this year I'll I'll fly for live
any H I might go to a Rangers game when
my brother comes out to visit cuz I'm
just like I just want to see it want to
go to the I heard Long Island
Islanders or the New York Island New
York island I heard those games were
crazy the fans were just like nuts
really okay I'll have to I'll have that
was when they were in Long Island and
now I think they're in now yeah oh my
God I bet it was insane in Long Island
just a bunch of trash bags it's like a
Eagles fan oh I and that's that's the
thing is without Green Bay like owning
the Packers they would have moved that
team a long time ago yeah oh it's true
any giant owner is just going to find
some less passionate but it can be less
passionate cuz it's the big Market will
still make more money La yeah it's it's
a joke to me that the Chargers are there
and even when the Niners play the Rams
it's so rewarding as a Niners fan cuz
it's all red but it's like it's kind of
preposterous that a team that won the
Super Bowl gets absolutely cucked out in
their own building yeah we call it Levi
South and it's okay is he okay this guy
bubble wrap
him can you imagine if you were staring
at the wall this whole game it' be very
funny
um oh my [__] all
right this game is demoralizing dude
well you just I mean you know it's close
is it it doesn't feel it's actually
closer than it feels like yeah it feels
like a big blowout yeah it's a two
possession
game
I think Jordan Le on I think yeah but I
think he had a Liz Frank last year I
think the Packers used to play a lot of
games in Milwaukee yeah that's right
there was like a there was some you'd
know better Adam I'm sure there's some
like like green and gold like ticketing
thing and they would play some games in
Milwaukee have you been to Milwaukee
yeah Milwaukee I like Milwaukee's cool
but I did not go I've done Milwaukee and
Madison yeah
yeah hear the club in Madison is unreal
amazing it's amazing have you have you
done hilarities in Cleveland yeah fun I
I didn't know I yeah I just didn't know
I was like I'm going to Cleveland who
knows oh my God it was incredible great
they so much fun they really do that
[__] suck dude Brock a touchdown oh okay
this iuk season has been coming for like
four years it's always been in the
offseason it's always been like
no yo uh ah yeah bro Brock was not
celebrating so let's
go oh thank god
dude I should be a better better fan I
should know my offensive lineman but I
was like who the hell is that guy he was
the one that guy H earlier I think no I
think that was a Oh that was a defensive
L yeah defensive line so my brain is
cried this got though by
Brock right there that was actually a
great throw no Brock isall security
thing is it's wild but it's so sick yeah
when it doesn't work then people freak
out but it looks so cool I would do
every chance that I yeah if I caught one
pass I'd be doing that that's just what
we do [__] kidding me if it's not 11
it's 19 and he's got room to
run see what you guys got to do is you
got to use the whole field like that
it's just sick dude this game is killing
me I just [__] hate it there's
Brock's Cho of a father
[Laughter]
looking like a whole
thumb I mean this guy looks incredible
yeah he looks
good it's just smooth just set the feet
I mean that's a
dime he knows who he is dude that's what
it's all
about just a smart guy Class Act lead
I hate it so much I hate it so much
what's up do you watch basketball how do
you feel about the NBA season I don't
know if I have a favorite I think I
would just go with the Bucks just cuz
who the [__] else but yeah they got Dame
so yeah they'll have to figure out the
defensive piece but I think they just
need one more good perimeter Defender I
mean the nuggets are still there oh yeah
the what happened it's it's funny it
took me a second I was like wait a
second who won oh yeah the nuggets did
cuz they just made it look easy you know
Brock py that [__] y looks so
unhappy to be playing basketball again
though it's yeah it's unbelievable every
little Arc of that whole thing was the
the after they won and and they're doing
the press conference and they're like
like I have to stay for the [__]
parade oh God are you looking forward to
having a parade what no when when is
parade Parade's Thursday oh my gosh guys
I have to go home so funny and then he
then you see him in Serbia that's what
right and he's just watching like horses
pull a dude on like a little wooden
carriage and he looks so happy he looks
like a guy on asset at Coachella he's
just deeply in his bag just feeling
himself what a what a treasure all right
third and two at the 12 yard line or
whatever it is I am uh won't surprise
anyone based on everything I've been
talking about for let's just put that in
for
George nonsp special needs
George
come on
bro God this is an
Assa I gotta check that's right
Brook it's just what we do
son I mean this is out of hand I meant
we were talking about Chubbies earlier
they're having a a a watch party at a
bar in SF like for KD cuz we have him so
they're going they're going off right
now oh shots are being poured at the
recck room are you still working with
chubby I am basically I have like one
week left left of doing part-time stuff
so barely but well grab a bunch of
shorts for us on the way out
honestly okay that went in uh we should
remember to do that yeah I'm going to
text you
actually Chad can you just cheer me up
dude just you know give me some money or
something you know that'd be
great dude non special needs George KD
has three touchdowns isn't he we did
manifest that D we manifested it uh yeah
Niners fans and Cowboys fans are annoy
fans who win are annoying right that's
just oh yeah well that's why Cowboys
fans became annoying is because of the
uh initial win since 95 either though
now that I think about it yeah we've
been really close I mean the thing is
we've got we've been able to do exciting
things since then we had the Harbaugh
era yeah um the one non Baum I'm a fan
of is is U ofm so it's was kind of great
to lose Harbaugh but he goes to Michigan
I got to keep him in my life why U of M
my best friend went there actually my uh
my grandpa went there and so like every
summer we go back to Michigan and so
like when I was like three years old
we're like kicking field goals in the
big house on the field you could just
walk in back in the day really and uh
and then I ended up going to a you know
a college that didn't even have a
college football team so I was able to
just keep my allegiance dude we my best
friend parents went to U ofm and then he
went to U ofm and it's just like it's a
thing it's a whole different thing it's
a thing dude and then my cousin went to
OSU and the hatred they have for each
other is so funny it's it's amazing cuz
it like obviously the big 10's about to
change with all the new teams coming but
right now unless Penn State goes on a
run it's we're kind of looking at each
other at the end of the year going you
going to [__] me or am I going to [__]
you like let's OSU has kind of owned you
all the last like 15 years right until
the last three yeah or two two yeah but
when they when Harbaugh finally did it
that was a that was
one of the more fun Sports viewing
experiences I couldn't believe it
because I've been watching this game
every year and just oh there's no hope
there's no hope and that year there was
a ton of uh people were on Harbaugh's
ass and uh and when they finally won it
was just it was Euphoria y'all boat
raced him last year right you scored
like three touchdowns in the fourth
quarter I believe so yeah I don't even
remember like the Cowboys are going to I
can't even say it like of any [__]
belief
[Laughter]
whatsoever I just hate the Niners so
much dude
yeah like they're just the worst [__]
everything about them they're so good
and it's so annoying and ners fans are
stupid and the city of San Francisco
sucks and you you just don't deserve
good things you got the Warriors already
like it's all so annoying yeah I'm
interested to see what happens with the
dubs the Chris Paul thing is going to be
that I don't think will work but I don't
think much will occur there but you know
we could bubble wrap him for a while
maybe just you got four ring though so
whatever whoes pretty nice who do y'all
lose y'all oh Jordan pool yeah that's it
yeah and he was becoming a he was
becoming an issue yeah prob he was he
was like a hope he was the hope of like
the whole Next Generation and whenever
Curry comes out a new Curry comes in and
but it was it was tough for him to
perform in his limited knock the life
out of that yeah I don't think getting
knocked out by the emotional heart of
your team helps Vibes yeah but uh you
know doesn't help confidence it's not
great that would bother me I get salty
if someone like says something mean to
me at work you know if my boss knocked
me out I don't know if I would be able
to
perform I mean Mike has done
nothing what do the Dallas Cowboys and a
Chick-fil-A manager have in Comm I'm
imagine that's going to they don't work
on Sundays there it
is they're against Case well that's
actually that's a really good response
well that worked
oh
man oh [__] this is the
[Applause]
worst it's hard to be a fan when it's
like every time you play a good team you
you you come up short and then you still
win 11 10 games it just teases you it's
a weird spot to be in cuz you you get
into that role where you're like okay do
we have the right guy what are we doing
are we a piece away do we need to sell
the future you'd almost like it it would
almost be kind of fun to be an Arizona
Cardinals fan right now you have Josh
dos and you're like every day is a new
psychedelic Adventure we might beat the
Cowboys or we might you know are we
going to give life back to the Bengals
you don't know are we going to get Caleb
Williams yeah who knows every day is a
new exciting Adventure I argue with my
well they're so hopeless and so bad my
brother- andlaw is a Jets fan mhm and we
argue who has it worse cuz you're just
never going to be good right and the
Cowboys will always tease you to think
they're going to be good and they're not
they'll get one game away from the
playoffs or they'll lose the playoffs
because Dak can't [__] slide one
second earlier or whatever stupid thing
Jesus that's not going to be it
yeah I was like did that get whistled he
started High stepping
unbelievable what exactly was the re
there I mean that wasn't going to be for
that
guy I mean this is Mike's asking him the
same question that I just asked he's
going what what exactly were we doing
there sir I
yeah I mean this is
bad it's a lot of air to put under a
ball with a safety hanging out out
there this is the worst
I'm so broken as a
man that that's tough I think there's
one comment in here that might cheer you
up because I think I missed them what is
it did you see the Heavies on P's mom no
I didn't catch those dude I'm going to
have to keep a look out for those C is
looking it up right now milkies dude
poppy Gordo I'm with you dog I'm over
and [__] this game I wish there was
something else to I should have thought
of this before this game but oh Big Bird
party Dam big bird is that his Carrie
birdie oh my god dude football mom
Instagram is how old is she I don't know
she kind of got it though scroll down I
mean she's probably posting her family
right he still lives with a roommate
Brock party did you read that article I
love that yeah click the middle that's
going to be has a choice it's because
San Francisco is too expensive if we're
talking I mean that would be he down
right there dude what are we saying bro
she's got the heaven spes
Jesus oh my God KN KNX
table kin spes is good oh my god
dude yo akos I got you tell me shador
Sanders wouldn't be a perfect Dak
replacement this is what bothers me when
people say [__] like that is like you
think the Cowboys are getting the number
two pick next year I don't think that uh
I don't think that shter is going to
come out this year but yeah that's I
mean I said next year but I meant 2025
yeah the
hey you know you know who be great on
the Cowboys is Patrick Mahomes yeah dude
the Cowboys should just trade Dak for
Patrick Mahomes and then all their
problems are solved yeah yeah
it's is there is there a world in which
Shanahan gets fired by the
Niners what I I mean like ever or like
like in two years he just keeps coming
up short I don't I I think that that is
definitely like a talk radio sort of
narrative and I but I would hope they're
not stupid enough like look if your
team's sniffing around the Super Bowl
you get one quarter away one year you
get uh a stupid dropped interception
away from going back another year you
get a quarterback the uh the year the
Rams won is a is a is a Super Bowl that
we should have had because jasi tart
dropped a basically it was like a fair
catch punt of an interception that
Stafford threw he drops it and otherwise
we win that game uh same thing with
Jimmy misses the pass in the Super Bowl
Brock P's elbow explodes and then even
Josh Johnson I was like there's a chance
he gets concussed we don't even have a
quarterback if you're in the NFC title
game that much and things happen like
things happen if you're a good enough
organization that you're that consistent
you don't throw that away for for
[__] who who's the it's always that
it's like okay we don't like what we
have what's the plan you think Chris
mcaffry ever thinks that God doesn't
like the 49ers because San Francisco is
full of so many homosexuals uh I don't
think that that thought never crosses
his no I don't think so because if he's
a Christian guy everything happens for a
reason but he's a Christian you think
you think these dudes wouldn't be
plundering each other's holes if uh All
Humans weren't created in God's image
what this Christian I think the thought
has to have crossed his mind Nick BOS is
for sure Nick BOS is for sure you know
what I like about Nick Bosa I don't
think he does too much thinking I think
he just I think he has one job dude he
just gets after that quarterback I mean
he's a simple man is this time going
regulation speed I feel like they slowed
it down I think we put the game on slow
slow motion but I really like that I'm
not seeing Christian mcaffry running the
ball but I would love to know what's
going on with Elijah Mitchell who is he
I don't know he is a running back that
before Christian came was going to be
our rb1 but kept getting hurt uh but I
don't think he's hurt and he's shown
signs of being a good player but I would
think this would be a time to mix him in
a little bit
is John does John Lynch do anything or
does Mike Shanahan run the whole thing
Kyle Shanahan Mike Shanahan is having a
margarita in the Press Box John Lynch is
the GM yeah I know but does he do
anything or no no no he he GMS it up
there's uh he he jams hard
dude he uh oh that's what I expected
yeah you do expect more that Brock I I
read an article they actually have like
obviously they they have strong opinions
personel wise but you know Kyle's
focused on um calling plays John makes
most of the Personnel decisions but when
they have a disagreement they brought in
some like this is some very Bay Area
[__] they brought in like a Stanford
Professor who specializes in like
mediation and negotiations and they go
through like a process to uh determine
you know what they should do so that
they don't fight basically oh God and
then they then they F then they 69 I
hate I hate everything that's what I'm
saying I hate everything about
everything that you do why is he
in when your biggest concern is that
you're using your best player too much
in a big game that's my concern all year
dude I I it's really we are built to win
the Super Bowl we just got to land the
plan you know the NFC East has not had a
repeat champion in like 17 years or some
crazy statistic I did not know that I
have a feeling based on this game that
that's not something we need to worry
about continuing I think I think that
streak ends this
year hey look the Cowboys are bringing a
blitz and no
pressure wide open there we go
Jawan I want to
cry just so bad it's just so bad dude
God damn it yeah this hasn't given you a
lot to be fired up about we got to think
of something for blowouts Kev we got to
think of something to fill the time
because this is the Pledge of Allegiance
isn't actually long enough I watched
Coco with my wife last night if you want
to put that back on we'll both cry we'll
all cry but tears of
joy the Rams are built to win the Super
Bowl that's so funny yeah they're built
to win the Super Bowl in
they're built to win a Super Bowl before
Co oh V's coming oh thank god dude yo
our boy Vala is coming Yad Khan finally
a dude who smashes yeah oh that's true
that's true
dude is Jen
awake cuz they're GNA whatever Buzz her
in yo yo Adam wrong game to kick this
off with dude this is a
[__]
sodomizing that's what they're doing
this is what they would do in San
Francisco what we do baby sodomizing the
Cowboys God damn it
dude for every seven points a Cowboys go
down you have to take 2
Mig from now on make it a make it a
getting now I'm into that I'll do that
yeah yeah okay let's do that just get
eded up so for every for every touchdown
the Niners scored from now on and the
Cowboys don't score on the next drive I
have to take a
some I can't say the word but you know
what I mean yeah Edibles some
good
I want to the subway just blasted
staring at
people gen G yes I'm going to keep doing
this every week and it's not always
going to be the Cowboys losing I I don't
think I have a feeling those are some
mad fellas over there let's look at your
upcoming schedule and see what we're see
what we're thinking yeah we need things
to do yeah you yeah you got to start
doing the post postmortem analysis what
a [__] nightmare
dude
yeah know it's not over but it's over
it's not looking good okay you got a Get
Right game next week oh actually you
have a buy week so there's you know no
Chargers next week I think is next
Monday oh it is the 16th oh it's Monday
night so you get you're at Chargers
that'll be a home game a lot of Dallas
people are going to want to go to La
Cowboys are not that good on grass it
seems is that a grass field natural
grass I don't I know that it's a dumb
but I think they might have natural oh
this is a problem so we lost Trayvon
Diggs for the year our best our well not
second best our second best is Gilmore
but our third best corner who replaced
Trayvon digs just left the game yeah
that's tough to
overcome so this guy we just traded for
he was a second round bust for the Jets
and we traded our second round bust for
him straight up just a couple of Busters
yeah but it doesn't even matter cuz it's
you check get in
there so you've got a interesting
schedule uh you go you go uh Chargers
Rams I feel like you you should win both
of those should Rams will be tough
they'll both be tough but I think you
you win both of those but now you're
going at home I think they'll be good
now you get the Eagles away the Eagles
suck dude whatever who cares who gives a
[__] who cares [__] Eagles suck uh
Giants at home there you go you're
cruising there Panthers Commanders
Seahawks now Eagles again Bills Dolphins
Lions you're going to have down the
stretch is going to be tough Bills
Dolphins Lions way to end it dude I'm
excited to see lions lions Cowboys I
don't give us an idea of where
everyone's at yeah I also I I just need
to pick a different team I I wish to God
I wasn't born in Dallas sometimes great
City but having a root for the Cowboys
is such a constant nut
KCK God if you could pick a team that
wasn't the Cowboys who who would you
think it would be fun to be a fan of oh
God the Chiefs but the Dolphins right
now would be really fun yeah the Chiefs
would be F do you see how like santinos
kind of like become adopted by the
chiefs no so Santino is like friends
with uh he end he's like friends with
Kelsey and Mahomes so he like goes out
and like parties with them and golfs
with them and he's obviously a Chicago
guy he's a Bears fan but you can just
take that off and you get nfca so he can
kind of guilt-free has wedged himself in
with the Chiefs during this run by
knowing the a [__] dude I know
Andrew Santino's a [__] what a
loser I think it's a great move I'd love
to golf with you guys it's a great move
I'm jealous it's a great move I 1,00%
want to do that hey Miami if you want to
embrace me I lived there during the
pandemic and I loved it I didn't want to
come back to New York remember that
remember that just think about it you
know what I mean me and Mike MC Daniels
Hit The Vape together would you rather
move to Miami or s San Diego San Diego
but Miami was great was great and you
did you were already there you didn't
want didn't want to come back a
wonderful place it's an odd
[Music]
place you'd regret becoming a fan of the
Dolphins immediately one good SE dude I
think that's going to change with your
coach dude I do I wouldn't worry about
that yeah he's fun it's a the Dolphins
are a fun team to be a fan of right now
too cuz they're just the way they play
is just raw speed so there's just dudes
running crazy all the time they got a
chain now Austin hibs pointed out
something that I I clocked in the moment
but didn't really take in when the Don
Bland got hurt and you were like yeah
that's a tough thing to overcome it was
so insultingly nice like it was so like
you're not even worried you're just like
pitying now yeah no I think you guys are
trying hard we're not I don't think we
are I don't think we
are guys's got the old fireman hel on
that's embarrassing man you're going to
the game with the your [__] face
painted like an idiot and then you're
just getting your doors blown it's tough
in the opposing Stadium that's the thing
that that's the thing that does suck
about sports is when when you win it's
so incredible because you don't know
what's going to happen which is the
power of sports but when you go to a
concert and you dress like a fool you
get the experience that you want pretty
much every time you're undefeated and if
not you're appalled if someone doesn't
deliver on performance like what the
[__] was that yeah but if you go to a
show and it's just you can dress crazy
it's always good happy it's good you
know your team wins do Molly and it's
great never done Molly oh it's fantastic
I've heard it's the best it's great you
should do it I mean you know if you want
to DMT seems fun also seems like a fun
time also great it the thing with that
is it it can go more directions but it's
uh use check get the fullback involved
Everybody Eats Everybody Eats in this
family 3510 you know what I mean this is
crazy
this is crazy thanks for having me over
man this is good time I hate everything
I'm so mad about this guys if you want
to see me on the brink of suicide this
is it losing to this team by this much
it's almost worse than the Eagles
almost soders Dan soders took Miami too
so dude I don't know who the [__] yeah
he did take Miami and that's I love yeah
it's fun to just NAB a little team here
and there yeah I've kind kind of snag
Green Bay a little bit but which again
you wouldn't be able to do too much a
ners fan why does he even need Miami I
know yeah what an ass yeah when you know
the guy it's kind of fun oh dude the
Chiefs is the one though Chiefs is
unbelievable and it's like oh what's
your connection to the Chiefs oh I know
uh Patrick Mah yeah cuz you can't you're
not even like can't be like oh no I'm
friends with the best players yeah
were're my friends dude I I love how the
the Taylor Swift Travis Kelce thing was
like like everything for a period of
time and then she didn't go to the game
this week they weren't in prime time and
it's like kind of done yeah I think it's
kind I mean I guess they're together I
hope they're together I I root for it
yeah I I just saw Kelsey rolled his
ankle yeah he came back in the game
though scor a touchdown it looked a
little that was one of my prize picks
that he would score Justin Jefferson did
not so I lost again and I'm losing this
one because the ners keep scoring
touchdowns I know Adam chillinsky just
asked is this worse than bombing you
know what because of how long it is it's
worse than
bombing because this is three and a half
hours of like kind of bombing it's not
me bombing but it's bombing yeah it's
tough and you're just yeah and usually
like you said you would have turned this
you'd actually be like asleep by now you
completely moved on now all you still
got to watch this it's not going to be
fun V's coming over he's going to be
vaping up a storm oh God damn it dude
vaa and he's B so I you know he's just
going to enjoy my misery
regardless is he here I don't
know oh yeah I got to hit the
Eddie all right I'm going to get the
Eddie oh yeah that's right you want you
want in uh no I'll I'll hold off I if
you score a touchdown cator Eddie if you
score a touchdown I'll do right they're
they're 2.5 uh yeah they're light d i
that's reasonable well they're five but
you just take half okay cool yeah
prepare one for the touchdown you guys
may or not score otherwise I'll take one
on the
way uh Clinton yeah you're right it
might have taken a while to uh to churn
through the internet but we're we're
getting out there we're pushing Clips
out man I did think this game was going
to hang on a little bit longer I thought
this was I thought we we might have a an
exciting one on our hands but all right
there you go
fast acting they're supposed to be fast
acting look at that I'll keep them off
screen right I know what the rules are
oh yeah that's right that's right that's
right just some Sour Patch Kids Sour
Patch Kids
organic there's
Jorge all right
guys there we go we on y we just bite
it Moody Michigan kicker oh Adam I just
did Chicago uh a c like last week I was
yeah I was at Zan's uh Wednesday th so
we're good so I just missed Chicago
hopefully back at some point but
probably not for a bit since I was just
there super fun
though you ever do zany downtown in
Chicago oh the best oh it's so fun the
absolute best the vibe in there I it's
just the old comedy club Vibe where they
just hang pictures over every goddamn
inch of the place the only thing that
would make it better is if it was wide
instead of long yeah yeah the people in
the back are are deep I told them I
would pay for them to move the stage and
they still wouldn't do it yeah they have
what they do now which is great is
they've rigged up like three cameras so
you can get great shots without even
bringing extra
stuff o i mean what in the absolute
[__] oh we got someone in in England at
3:50 a.m. love that
hey harry that's you got a good English
name dude that's a good English name got
to be 3:50 a.m. got to be unemployed
which I love yeah yeah you can tell by
what he's asking for Vi vibing dude I
respect that
Harry potentially confused at why the
football players are using their hands
but yeah that's a pick oh my [__]
goodness
I mean go down and take a photo
fellas I mean you know I just whatever
bro whatever score another touchdown so
I can take the other half of this thing
we're going to do the defense turnover
[Laughter]
pick this is
terrible we'll hang that one my life is
falling apart yeah that's great right
[Laughter]
there oh son of a [__] dude
dude what a nightmare this
is
supern well you know I predicted the
Cowboys before the year to lose to the
Chiefs but I just don't see how that's
possible right
now yeah I mean look I am uh very very
biased uh in this but I think the Niners
are going to win the Super Bowl I think
the team's built for it all I needed to
see is if pie could steer it and it
looks like he he's got the Steady Hand
um
AF
well is the flag you said gosh going to
be you're going to be seeing your little
pyramids before bed
tonight well here we go guys there it
is holy
[__]
George on Micah there oh no he just
chipped him yeah but they oh wow kind of
got taken out by his own
dog just
wide well
guys before this thing is over I'm going
to start you're not going to see the
full effects of how zoned I get you're
going to be bro at this rate with the
time outs and the injuries I really
don't think I can do any more yeah I'm
such a lightweight and it would ru my
episode of flr tomorrow I'm already I
already have new prep don't do that
don't do that can you say who you're
having on oh we had no guest boys app oh
boy app oh I love those that'll be very
fun saddest Casting Couch ever I
know I I won't chug a beer I'll never
drink but I'm on the Eddies
so if we had a beer I'd chug a beer the
problem with Edy is they're delicious
they're delightful they're fantastic and
then the weed starts hitting and you're
like I deserve a snack you know I
want
yeah it should all taste like medicine
the whole thing should be that
amount you know what I mean like just
the whole pack is worth this many
milligrams that's
it then I don't have to eat one like a
[__] adult yeah did you ever have
chibu back in the day they were like
like the size of a Tootsie Roll and they
were like 500 Mig oh so you'd have like
famous like Joey Diaz would just eat
like three of them and just like and
just figure out what life is yeah but I
would I would like I would I remember I
would get them and I would like I would
be I'd have like a steak knife and I'd
be slicing them into like the smallest
possible and I would and I'd be flying
dude I'd have like one tiny bit and be
like I'm going a micro do tonight next
thing I know I'm staring at a leaf
trying to figure out how many veins it
has oh
[__] yo
Chad help help me out bro I in bad shape
he really is give me something else to
talk about that's not the game dude 42
to
10 uh will we come out to skankfest next
year I I couldn't go this year because I
was uh in Houston but I would love to go
next year cuz I went the year before
this and it was an unbelievable time yo
[__] them [__] everything I'm not doing
nothing cancel all my shows I quit
comedy
why the [__] did I decide to do this
this
week son of a [__]
dude son of a [__] I love how you're
like you won't get to see the full
effects of this and someone was like bro
you're already 34s deeper into the couch
this is misery this is not yeah sadness
this is not substance related this is
misery pure
misery oh actually this shouldn't matter
because uh when Rogan came on flagrant
we just you know what I mean you'll be
you'll be you you'll be fine I'm saying
you guys oh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh Saturday Night Live is back so
if I wanted to be less happy than less
you know what I mean like more already
Davidson and Ice spice on the same app
which is just guiding his dick once
again like that's crazy you can't you
can't who ice spice oh that's great dude
they already R black girl that's that's
I need that's what P that's like uh the
last Infinity son yeah INF obviously
Beyonce is off the table but like just a
bad black chick that's possible the
final infinity stone that's this one
right there and then it's everything is
done you can't stop him he's got that
Thanos [__]
yeah oh I infity no I think I feel it I
think things are spinning there it
is yeah things are
spinning I'm GNA sink back into this
couch
guys what othera wow what's up buddy
welcome to my hell how are
you how you doing buddy what's up I uh
we made a deal that the when the Niners
scored i' hit good to see you man so up
what's up baby how you doing guys say
hello to Imad Khan AKA vaa vaa films vaa
here guys can we please first of all
talk about how [__] far away you live
dud Jesus Christ
where do you live bro we don't have to
go
there what region I'm I'm in Brooklyn
okay we just wanted to be away from the
poor people son I I'm coming from the
studio right now and yeah hell thing it
took me so [__] long to get here yeah
it's a hell of a thing I called an Uber
my bank called me they're like um I
think we're your identity has been
stolen there's no way a super man like
you who takes the train to work every
day would pay $80 half your paycheck to
come you dropped no no no I'm just
kidding no it's expensive it's far it's
mad far so we made a deal because the
Cowboys are getting their asses [__]
so hard that uh anytime they Niners
scored a touchdown I would hit a piece
of in edible and so I'm ners are scoring
I'm getting pretty Zed dude I I I think
I need to cut it off but uh this says
fast acting if you want in and it is
also guys congratulate V this is a big
weekend for his people what what
happened what
what are you talking about what no just
the news the World Cup oh yeah the World
Cup yeah wait what are you talking about
the World Cup dude the World Cup shut up
dude don't don't get me killed bro no
I'm saying we went to Toronto with
Andrew is a big week you know what I
mean you guys had a big week yeah you
guys had things going on you know I mean
what are you up to over there I'm just
saying what is this is this sponsored no
oh okay yeah but if you want in you know
get no I can't I can't do that can't do
that um wait wait so what's going on
with the Cowboys this is the worst they
are getting destroyed V who's your team
by the way I don't even I know your guy
was Tom Brady honestly I don't even want
to say because what happened to my team
today was worse than what's happening
right now Patriots
yeah wow this is a couch of misery I
should almost leave and let you guys
talk cuz third world country third world
football teams you know what I mean
that's what we
R yeah I think I don't know man I think
I thought you were just a Brady fan I
didn't think you were no no no I I I
became a Pats fan because my oldest
brother grew up in in Boston ah and uh
this is when I still lived and it is oh
my
god
wow AOS is about to go to the underworld
dude BR this is
crazy yo you know Stephen A Smith F
tomorrow this is actually this this is I
might have foretold this I there was
this is the only way this could have
happened this might be the Tre Lance
Revenge game oh I didn't think we were
going to get to see Tre Lance but we are
here in the house that Tre Lance never
quite built yeah and he could get to see
his first snap as a cowboy I mean you
have to sit back after four picks I
would think oh L is traed Cowboys yeah
yeah why are they not putting him in
well probably for the same reason we
traded him there
cuz they've seen him in practice and
he's not all that yeah but there's
nothing to lose I mean if he if he plays
even decent if he scores one touchdown
would NE and then You' have trade yeah
well they're not going to trade him but
you want to start seeing what you
[__] got there I would think no I
would love for the Cowboys to get
something for him trade-wise you want
him to trade him already he's not worth
I him to show enough to get traded right
we just did that with him so I don't
think teams are going to bite on that
yeah but if he has a couple good games
that's all he's so athletic he's not
going to get to play full games for you
in a playoff season with can I be honest
with you the room is spinning okay so
the room is [__]
moving this is crazy that was the best
response I've ever had to a sports take
hey can I be honest with you the room is
spinning dog
buddy your boy
floating bro we got more Indian right
there for a second
buddy is
floating oh my God the room is floating
yeah this is a fun time I haven't done
this in a while it's been a long time
since I've done
this I so you're off five right now just
five cuz that shouldn't be too five
gummies no no no no no Jesus Christ I
was like what no but I don't I I get
this is like four or five times a year I
well a little more than that but like
less than once a month I do this right
right right right also guys don't be Red
by this fake ass Casting Couch setup a
lives in a [__]
massive place on the 75th floor my ears
are still popping it's unbelievable I go
I had to go through like four levels of
security to Bro the the elevator had a
flight attendant bro it was
crazy they looked at me when I walked in
they're like sir there's no way anybody
here knows you br Brown you got money
you know what I mean you know people
with money I just spent half my paycheck
on a uber ride coming in true no that's
true that's true V pay me
more y you're welcome to stay on this
couch anytime you can bring any of your
hores here if you'd like to I could
never do that to my sweet poby outside
that's true that's true she would be
happy happy you couldn't be whing it up
with that lovely painting looking at you
do deed
grandmother Jesus you can't be [__]
out his leg
over
the over the painting not it dude I walk
in Namaste
a yo I got to decorate this wall with
something we'll figure that out we'll
figure it out yeah do something this yo
we're going to build you weren't there
early flagrant dude early flagrant was a
[__] was this engine room yeah so we
built it up that's what we're going to
do with this we're going to build it up
over time we're going to get better C
you living here for like 2 years I'm
talking about this for the
stream I never decorated this wall cuz
who cared about this wall that wall had
it my laptop was here I oh wow dude we
took Glock out it's darnold time this is
the darnold Trey Lance see now we've got
a storyline darnold took that man's job
that's true do we get a showdown also
you guys you guys let him go for Brock
pie Brock is the man you look at the
score there my I mean yeah I know I I
obviously I see it but it's like Brock
now Brock has been lightened up today I
said the same thing I said the same
thing light up Brock look Trey Trey has
a lot of potential but he never really
got to play a lot of football so he
makes a lot of mistakes the Niners are a
beautifully built roster who can't have
someone who makes mistakes and Brock is
honestly he's better than Jimmy he's the
best guy that we've had in Shanahan's
offense because he knows what his limits
are and he just uh he doesn't like go
above his means yeah he he knows how to
run the offense efficiently what Vander
has a like a neck thing or like a narrow
spinal column or something and
then
not good I mean anybody that's ever
watched Friday Night Lights knows not to
tackle with your head down yeah you know
what I'm saying any white boy with a
neck roll is going to get a concussion
dude that's just what Happ remember you
remember the
neck I mean Romanowski right yeah Rome
also uh uh what's his name the Redskins
guy the safety who who passed away oh
Sean Taylor Shawn Taylor bro rip the
goat I thought you been a redin fan cuz
you're from Virginia oh no I mean
Redskins have like no like fans in the
like Virginia area it's weird it's cuz
Dan Snider ruined the team right but
also like they don't really have like a
solid fan base it's kind of
weird I've been to bro I've been to a
reton g or the commanders game sorry um
and like they're more like Cowboys fans
and it was a Pat's Redskins game or
commanders game and there were more like
random fans than actual I wonder if
you'll get your fans back back now that
SN sold the team I yeah cuz I've heard
that like I think it's like a it's a
beleaguered fan base like they're having
trouble rooting but I think there was a
time weren't they they're all wearing
the look at those two guys the field is
terrible I I hate that Lance is happy
about that like you shouldn't be shaking
this man and he took your job [__] him
yeah that's very cucky cucky right super
cucky yeah dude I should have known
right there the Cowboys are going to get
beaten 42 to 10 is crazy did you guys
were you guys watching the builds game
today yes yes bro damn I don't believe
in the Bills ever yeah me neither they
just one week they they look dominant
they're and then the next it just falls
apart also the Ravens game oh yeah that
was that was a [__] crazy ass game
that's another one I'm done believing in
yeah Lamar is like
believing he's supposed to win yeah he
doesn't win yeah oh come on
Trey
damn bro no I'm excited about this he's
going to light it up dude that is kind
of like she said that she delivered that
monotone but like you can tell he
responded to that she asked him about
his future in the NFL and he was like
[__] I'm
23 what I'm too high to think I need
clever to what
you you right wait did you take some too
no the deal the deal was yeah when they
if if the Cowboys were to theoretically
score a touchdown I would take some but
that's hilar hasn't really happened yet
so that's hilarious what up gen G what
up chat y'all have any UFO experiences
no but I've been probed a couple times
there you
go y I got you going through
it oh man yeah Stephen A is gonna have a
field day tomorrow he's goingon to be St
is about you want you want something to
I'm good man I'm
good ping oo who makes it though you or
Bobby I don't know I'm not I know I'm
not I
was I was just going to start talking to
this guy over here be look up a man
kev's kev's focused right now oh [__]
Trey Lance's about to get the rock dud
you got to Kev you got to get Kev a
bigger seat bro this guy is going
through it right now what a
punt back treay up
son oh God get shut up dude come on
Ronnie Bell go off how are there 8
minutes this game dud dude with the flow
d scari v climbed out a [__] long
enough to show up that's a good point V
you don't get to see V that often he
comes out of the cave dripping like a
slag
M he's neat deep in these [__] dude oh
my God that's hilarious that's all he
has to say very true though very true
very true I had a yeah no I had a very
um yeah I had a very late night last
night I literally just climbed out of
bed like 4 hours ago nice cuz we went
out we went out last night we went to
the Garden to go see black coffee sh all
of us I was amazing yeah watch going to
like a rave or like a like a electronic
like DJ thing at the Garden is like so
weird because the way they set it up the
the way they set up the stage like it's
a center stage kind of set up and then
the floor is wasn't full but then you
look around on on the on the on the
chairs and stuff and it's completely
full and every time there's a a a new
drop the crowd just goes crazy and it's
cascading all but when you look around
on the floor there's like not a lot of
people but then all the people start
cheering and you're like oh [__] that's
a lot of [__] people here my wife saw
the Afterparty at Mirage oh we supposed
to go to that she said it was crazy damn
wait did was he outside or was he inside
I don't know I was in South Carolina oh
okay at the comedy
zone were you guys sober I mean like not
Beyond
alcohol um I would say no but I wasn't
there so I'm just going to make an do it
for a while no no no no sh
no I I don't know how much I can say all
right I'll let him say tomorrow I'll let
him tell tomorrow I know how much I can
say cuz he'll tell us tomorrow I don't
know who's on your
chat the FED Joy oh you missed this
Squidward's house and B sy's Dome with
that Mega mine I don't get that I don't
get it sy's dome what do you get it we
were talking earlier about how I look
like Squidward's house but we're going
have to pull up sy's Dome here yo
somebody said he look like Squidward's
house on that [__] was so good somebody
said I look like an indifferent
llama that [__] was good bro I think
this one's a little less uh this one's a
little less on point yeah I mean it is a
he's just saying you got a big old big
old frosty I do I do have that you are
right about that but n it's not as good
as Squidward's house yeah Squidward's
house is fire I do love how they hit the
aerial shots of San Francisco and then
they cut quickly to the blimp that's an
hour and 10 minutes south so buddy
there's nothing is this Tre Lance oh
it's Cooper Rush Oh Tre [__] out of here
dog how Cooper Rush your Andy Dalton and
a safety n that was forward progress
okay cuz I was going to say I think we
have to to give aosh another one as a
suppository if
we we get a safety the old dornob
rule so Nick BOS is not vibing it's just
sitting there that
sucks aash looks like a bitcoiner that
did well that's false that's
not I might look like that first part of
the sentence is on
point I gosh looks
[Music]
[Applause]
look at that huh could Dak do that yeah
eight yard eight yard out route that's
kind of what he's been doing he's been
just slinging those but but you know the
the that deep out route is like one of
the hardest routes to throw for a
quarterback yeah but that was a that was
an eight- yard out that was a shallow
out right I feel like that's fairly easy
yo Nick Bosa got a [__] jaw line dude
that's a handsome guy I told you can you
pull up Nick Bosa like not in pads or
something I need you to see his body oh
I'm excited this is what I was talking
about Nick Bosa body shirtless Nick Bosa
shirt Bosa body he's usually wearing a
cut sleeve but you can see what's going
I mean that that doesn't even showcase
the legs as much there's a leg photo
that really sent people into Jes what
page is it on Joey yeah it's on page
seven yeah that's not it you need the
tighter pants that really ride the groin
and kind of showcase the whole thing
I'll see if I can find it it's my lock
screen
what a
man so that'd be the funniest [__] ever
to have shirtless nickb to your lock
screen yo you got to do that to do it if
you score if you score another touchdown
if we score another touchdown I will
make uh shirtless Nick Bose of my lock
screen yeah what do you guys think is
going to happen uh with um bich next
season I know I think he sucks dude yeah
I know I think Tom Brady made bill bich
at least at least at least they got to
get rid of him as the GM at least at
bare minimum GM he's been the
GM the last he can't be the GM anymore I
mean his you know what the last
successful draft was I don't even know
grank and Aron Hernandez holy [__] and
that's that all you got killer draft
that's it killer draft for
real I mean look he's he's done what any
successful business person does he's
started taking it slowly and he's turned
it into a family business and he's just
kind of enjoying his time there in
Foxboro but something's going to need to
change yeah I don't think Robert Craft
is just but will he will he do that will
he be willing to give up GM yeah I don't
know I don't
know I I honestly I'm not even that mad
at M Jones I think belich just [__]
ruined that kid really yeah bro I mean
his rookie season his first year playing
he did pretty well for a rookie you know
who else that was true for deck
so you know oh just multiple offensive
coordinators I don't know I'm not even
saying I'm not saying anybody ruin deck
I'm saying a lot of quarterbacks have a
good rookie year and then they kind of
get figured out Max sophomore year he
had a defensive coordinator as his look
at those
thighs guys I mean that's a
football we're now only talking about
why he look like why does he look like
ye that was kind of a tight photo that I
found I
was we are no longer talking about
football guys we're talking my man meat
dude I am that's Indian name you're a
substance guy I'm on substances
dude when is this game going to end holy
[__] get him there you go Ray Ray dude I
was thinking I I could keep live
streaming after this is over 3 and 1
half hours is so crazy long yeah I mean
I I think it would have felt faster if
you were enjoying the match yeah
probably uh and also you hadn't taken a
substance that notoriously slows down
time that was just cuz the Cowboys suck
I didn't choose to do that that's very
true that was not there's like a couple
things working against the Cowboys
didn't give up two touchdowns in 5
minutes yeah I wouldn't have had to do
that I mean it's really crazy that as
soon as we made the deal 14 points yeah
like the timing is uncanny it was crazy
what do you mean he he didn't do
anything in Michigan what are you
talking about who anytime they put Brady
in he [__] killed it in Michigan yeah
I yeah my again my best friend is a big
Michigan fan and Brady was great they
didn't like him CU they had Drew Henson
like recruit yeah he was like the Drew
hon actually ended up on the Cowboys he
went and played baseball for two years
first or something and that that kind of
screwed it
up yeah I wonder if belich is going to
go to some other
team and who yeah I mean I gu yes but I
think he has to retire or keep going I
don't yo also I love those are the
options I love that the Broncos lost
today why because you remember that's
right Shan was [__] on Nathaniel
hacket yeah and they put 31 yeah I kind
of forgot about that I'm so glad they
lost do the Broncos have their pick this
year yeah I think it's the Panthers who
don't the Panthers are horrible and they
don't have the Bears are going to suck
and they have the Panthers pick what if
they get the number one pick again and
they could get cayb Williams they'll
take it they'll take it you have to and
then you trade fields or yeah and then
you're going to have a high number one
too and you trade that if you can yeah
it's pretty solid that would work out
pretty well that' be great cmax the man
bro He is unbelievable he's so sick the
team was so good but once he got there
it's just turned into a different thing
it's like if he's healthy I mean how do
you stop it I mean you got Glock out
there I hate I mean who was that who was
the last he looks like shy La who Brock
oh tell me that's not shy lab dude yeah
kind of Laboy I would love a football
movie starring shy la like young sh
being insode or it's like post career
and shy laou like has CTE and he's just
like extra crazy I would watch but he's
a kicker
somehow I wouldn't say Shawn pyton is
overrated or that he hasn't done [__] I
mean he retired yeah but also he won a
Super Bowl very early and that was about
it crack
[Laughter]
I have shrooms if you want them at the
house I I'm sober guys I I might have
some residual stuff from last night not
saying I did anything [__] Bears did be
the 49ers but that's when we were trying
Trey Lance and that's why he's no longer
on the team last year yeah hey thank you
John C appreciate it dude we got a
special coming that [__] is going to be
amazing when is that uh coming out do
you have a I just watched down the last
show took I took notes on every show so
we start the official editing process
with all those notes this week how not
excited SL excited are you as soon as
you said yeah I don't look forward to it
I don't look forward
to fun part but it it's also fun to like
all right let's see we actually it's the
only it's the most important part but it
sucks every minute of is awful yeah Kev
you ready to edit this special we get
started tomorrow dude we need a rough
cut in two weeks I'm sending the
networks a rough cut in two weeks to see
if they want it on my terms if not suck
my
dick is that what you're going to do
you're going to basically be like here
here it is here's what it's going to
cost not even cost as much as like being
able to if a network takes it I need to
be able to give you guys on YouTube a
certain percentage of it otherwise I'm
not going to do it right I need people
to see it right as much as money is
great I need the fans to see it as many
as possible you want put it on
quibby the o with the quibby vertic the
whole thing on Tik Tok the hour vertical
special I heard they like long form one
full hour video TI Tok 10 minutes break
it up oh dude that would be fire yeah
yeah absolutely that's for sure that's
done that's not even a question yeah
well that's the whole thing if the whole
thing is on YouTube the whole thing is
on Tik Tok yeah when when's your when's
your new [__] coming out my new [__]
yeah uh I don't I don't have anything
but when's it coming out oh so like when
are we going to shoot it and when's it
coming out oh guys when you go sure
let's give V some love whenever you go
to the new Andrew Schultz Show life the
tour the video at the beginning is vaa
and it's beautiful and amazing thank you
man it's really [__] amazing it's
great took a lot took a lot of uh hard
work and cussing
out VA is gifted at that [__] though
yeah to to answer your question I mean I
have tons of stuff coming out every week
I put stuff out uh from this your Clips
are [__] hilarious thank you are you
editing those those yourself uh it
depends a lot of them yes and some no
but with the with editors that I work
with uh I'm very Hands-On and how I go
back and forth I get a few different
opinions and try to I I'll even send it
to people who just like are just friends
of mine and just be like what what do
you think um but whenever I've kind of
done a full tour with this hour we're
figuring out where we want to shoot
something and how we want to shoot it
and we will put something
together I mean the first thought the
natural thought is San Francisco
punchline it's my home Club it's a great
Club it's a amazing small intimate room
but so that's the idea to beat um so
we'll just see holler at is dude Schultz
me v i I would I would love to yeah I
might uh I was talking to Schultz I
might pull up on the studio one of the
days you're in this week and just no
doubt chat and ask a bunch of questions
you're going to Europe on yeah we leave
on Tuesday we go on Tuesday yeah we
leave oh [__] well maybe it'll be when
you get back yeah we'll be back I think
on the 23rd did you hear that [__] of
Europe yeah vaa is coming mine is mine
is Dublin and Scotland you guys are
[__]
ghouls [__] snaggle
tooth oh man don't want to crack me
out oh
lad yo Vala only takes Prime [__] dude
he's not settling for you you Scottish
[__] SES Loess moners no but for
there's any cute ones out
there yeah he's actually negging the
entire region which is a brilliant great
movie that's a nice learn from the best
thank you thank you Portland
sucks that is the way to do it dude with
especially with cui like I bet I can
show you a good time Honestly though
Honestly though the crowd in Portland
was [__] phenomenal cuz they hate
Portland cuz they hate that whole
culture and then they're going against
the oppos yeah there's enough people in
every town that aren't the stere aren
the
stere your city sucks dude your team is
good your city sucks own it I the
Cowboys suck that's what it is I'm
honest about I love San Francisco and I
love our team it's a terrible Place Bay
forever Su my dick the fans are good and
we invented that so you're welcome Su
you sucking my dick no you perfected
that it's getting really tense in here
guys
cut it with a knife no
dog wait get ready oh never mind misread
that do some crowd work on Joey and V
that'd be [__] weird no I'm not going
to do
[Laughter]
that yo 154 and then we're out of here
dude I'm so excited for this to be over
yeah I get to go you know what I mean
eat Munchies that's going to be fun
going to be really nice for you you guys
you never even got maybe you score a
touchdown here and I get sent on the
train with a little buzz but we'll see
we're going to have you back Joey and
we're going to watch and there's going
to be I want to do a game where we think
the Cowboys will for sure win or whoever
the losing team is yeah you're going to
get [__] gone wait yeah you're here
now right I'm here now I've moved here
how do you like it I I mean I moved here
September 12th and then I went on tour
for like 20 days so I've been here like
a total of like 5 days so I'm still
moving in but all that to say I [__]
love it dude I ask you where you live
but do you live close to the studio I do
oh I'm I'm I I can say I Lower East Side
oh oh that place sucks dude I like it
feels like home there's crazy nutcase
disgusting it's a disgusting place full
of mice crazy it's awesome we're on a
great Street we're a nice we got a ni
[__] rats and Vermin dude that's what
we do baby and I'm not talking about the
animals I'm talking about the Asian no
I'm
[Laughter]
kidding no but that place sucks dude
Lowery side sucks I love it what is it
what's good about go out you don't do
nothing yeah I 39 bro it's over going
out right but if I wanted but but but
here's the deal if I wanted to just live
in a nice uh space I would not have come
to New York like I need to be near stuff
to do outside San Francisco so us shitty
places well I went from San Francisco to
LA uh La uh do you know where La can be
nice yeah do you know where you CB
Franklin is no like Franklin Village it
was like like East Hollywood basically
that sounds ter if I go back to LA at
any point I would go west side and live
near the beach and but as we've
discussed we dominate the world and then
we move to San Diego and we chill there
I think that's the plan I think we set
up dude what if we just set up our own
world in San Diego can we get Schultz on
this plan he can build a club call
fathership and then we all go to San
Diego and we can Vibe dude sh would
never leave New York I know he well he's
like he he's a homer I get that I love
that yeah I always said when I have
enough money to retire I would retire in
San die that's exactly that's what I say
all the time bro it's perfect it's a
perfect place it's a perfect place the
food fire weather perfect beaches way
nicer than La people are friendly La
beaches suck first of all it's La
without it's LA with nicer people and
less traffic and less pollution traffic
can get a little Annoying there can get
dicey especially you go if you live
North County and then you're trying to
like get down like it's it can be a
little tough but it's not like LA right
no but the problem is it is there is one
route and in fact the LA traffic is
starting to extend to San like if you
try to go from LA to San Diego on a
Friday at like 4 o' I mean it'll take
you for [__] ever um see Clinton's
comment West Hollywood gay I said East
but yeah West Hollywood is bro it's what
that's do you know that did you know
that uh the gays are stealing phones
have you heard about this if you go to
the gay bars in West Hollywood they'll
steal your phone there's a whole ring of
gay phone criminal had my phone stolen
by gays like 15 years ago I had an
iPhone 3G stolen by gays they've been on
this racket for years yeah yeah yeah
it's not it's not it's under under
discusted they hit on me and like I had
my phone recording and set they walked
on stage got in my face started like
flirting me I was like guys I don't know
what's going on I I [__] one of them
and then they stole my phone
yeah only one part and when I say stole
my phone I left it on his nightstand but
why the why the thing why the clock stop
reset the game clock for what guys
stupid have some sense of the moment
[__] stupid don't you know akos is
zooted and he wants to start eating now
we have 10 more
seconds it took me 35 minutes to get
here just back look at Austin's
comment well [__] howdy fellas
getting to be about that time of the
hour got to hit the old dusty
trail Deo always looks like he's taking
off a bra who's he look like he looks
like somebody and I can't figure out who
dude 49ers team is so [__] stacked
it's
unbelievable
CAC Debo aay is now guy a Bosa Bo
hardgrave bro Fred Warner Fred War Dre
is a
dog
funga yeah if you guys don't beat Casey
this year I don't know when that's the
thing is like obviously I'm very happy
this team is built for but there has
been so much teasing in Niners land for
so many years that unless we actually
win people are going to melt down
heavily like it has to happen this year
that is that is where people are at the
comments everything they post on
Instagram Bower BOS people are freaking
out so this team is ready I feel good
about it and uh just keep on trucking I
also wanted for Kyle shanan I do too
yeah I want it for Kyle I want it for
Christian but mostly I want it [__] a
young man named me [__] San Francisco
the whole place sucks your organization
sucks nothing about you is good fans are
truly the worst no San
Francisco a guys are just completely
miserable human wens don't want you
norstrom don't want you nobody wants to
be in San Francisco you [__] suck as
a city you don't deserve any good except
for all the big tech companies H good
you got the tech company they make up
all the money on the oh yeah you got the
tech company as well that hey easy to
root for them huh Facebook we're on
YouTube Google s Carlos on the peninsula
shout out to my backend engineers at
YouTube We're be streaming on Tik Tok
next time turning it off TV just said
are you still watching like like why why
would you be why would you still be
watching are you still doing this you
[__] idiot oh my God oh my Lord
streaming is fun hey Uncle Phil came
back I can't believe I've never done
this before hey yo Uncle Phil what's
good dude I can't believe I've never
done this before streaming yeah WNBA
live stream is a great idea no Val
you're doing great dude I want that's
why I wanted you to be a part of I
thought you'd be great you know football
nobody else knows football that's do you
know that immigrants are like massive
Sports people because because because we
want to so bad that we we like we like
oh football Everyone likes football in
America okay well we got to learn
everything about football when I moved I
moved to the US my freshman year in high
school I my team was like the Patriots
by default which is my brother so but
everyone was like oh you're just like a
bandwagon fan I didn't even know what
bandwagon meant yeah yeah but I went and
literally rech you're out here trying to
buy concert tickets for a band called
wagon I am a band I'm a band wag fan
yeah but yeah like I I learned
everything because like I didn't want to
get roasted by all my that's really
interesting they want to fit in so bad
that they learn everything about like
even though I wasn't imigrant I was
still there was so few Indians in Dallas
at that time at least in my suburb I was
like oh I need to fit in the way yeah
that's a great Point yeah that is a
great Point yeah it's just in my blood
yeah hey guys thank you guys for
watching thank you guys for coming
through yeah for sure I still have to
prep for the episode and I'm high so
that's going to be fun is going to make
us some uh food right now yeah that's
true and uh that's true did you guys not
well that time of the hour Joey Avery
social media I'm on tour Joey avery.com
vaa films vaa films on tour as well uh
International tour unlike Joey
thundering
holes yeah dude yo we got to we got to
stream uh a World Cup yes India Pakistan
maybe well we we'll be in Australia oh
that's right we can just stream any uh
World Cup match let's do it I'm we can
also uh there's also the ability to just
Discord you like Discord video chat
people in oh [__] oh that might work and
then have two people on the screen same
time oh yeah yeah yeah like a little
Zoom pod man that was Kev by the way man
of not many words you know big Kev dude
he's going to do a stream mie he don't
watch football but we're going to bring
his big [__] Ass down on this couch
see what he got to say wait do you watch
sports c i us he just
did he didn't watch nothing dude he was
in that he was mod and heavy but you're
from
where you're you're not from New York I
was born and rais here yeah until I was
like 14 but you just moved here I moved
back he moved he moved to New York and
know he born and raised in New York and
then he moved to Michigan when he was
like high school and then he moved to
North Carolina when he was like like 20
oh 26 got it and then he moved here oh
[__] I mean yeah New York doesn't really
have that big of a sports culture right
no cuz people have things to do and I
mean that they they have so much going
on they don't have to watch sports we
didn't have much else going on plus they
don't really have football here like
towns that have football like high
school football college football I feel
like you know like the southern states
like East Coast Fans they do have are
very passionate though even though they
suck I mean Jets fans are rabid fans are
[__] bills is a whole another
scenario the city those are jets fans
are Long Island yeah but like if you're
Manhattan if you're any burrow maybe
Manhattan only you're not that in this
world yeah they just got the Knicks yeah
which also suck yeah so sorry guys
Rangers Yankees Yankees are
anyway thank you for watching I'm going
to prep for the podcast guys it was fun
being here V I love you Joe I love you I
love you love you all thank you for
watching